la science est ouverte
avant de démarrer nos travaux observons
ensemble une ligne de silence en hommage
aux trois policiers du commissariat de
Roubaix tragiquement décédé le weekend
dernier
merci
l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée du projet de loi relatif à la
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 à 2030 et portant diverses
dispositions intéressants à la défense
la parole est à Monsieur Sébastien
Lecornu ministre des Armées
merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Président de la Commission
de la Défense nationale monsieur le
président de la commission des affaires
étrangères monsieur le président de la
délégation pour les affaires européennes
madame et Messieurs les Présidents de
groupe mesdames messieurs les députés
monsieur le rapporteur de la commission
de la Défense nationale j'ai l'honneur
de vous présenter un projet loi de
programmation militaire pour la période
2024 2030 le 15e depuis le début de la
5ème République et depuis que c'est loi
de programme en matière de défense
nationale spécificité bien française il
faut le rappeler existe ce texte de loi
pour lequel nos armées les directions et
services du ministère travaillent depuis
un an a été préparé sur l'autorité du
Président de la République chef des
armées en lien étroit est très en amont
avec le Parlement et les acteurs du
monde de la défense ils cherchent à
traduire une conviction simple la seule
qui vaille les menaces qui pèsent sur la
nation française n'ont jamais été aussi
diverses et protéiformes que depuis la
fin de la guerre froide a bien des
égards et nous place face à un défi
aussi important que celui ont dû relever
les gaullistes dans les années 60 cette
programmation acte en effet du retour
d'une compétition plus dure entre les
grandes puissances sur fond de
prolifération nucléaire de la permanence
d'un risque terroriste qui n'a pas
disparu et dont malheureusement on ne
parle plus assez mais aussi de
l'émergence de nouveaux espaces de
conflictualité qui découlent ou qui sont
le reflet de saut technologique rapide
et brutaux il faut bien le reconnaître
comment témoigne la militarisation du
cyber de l'espace ou des fonds marins
ces menaces s'entendent autant dans leur
approche classique mais aussi et surtout
pour une puissance nucléaire comme la
nôtre dans une hybridité qui nous invite
à penser différemment c'est là où la
dimension de transformation de cette LPM
ce qui ne signifie pas rupture
intervient plus que jamais
ces menaces nouvelles ou anciennes se
cumulent désormais plus qu'elle ne se
succèdent cette programmation militaire
a été construite en les regardant
froidement en y intégrant les
spécificités françaises avec nos forces
mais aussi il faut le reconnaître nos
vulnérabilités elle n'a pas pour but de
tirer des conclusions comme certains
commentateurs ou pseudo experts nous y
ont souvent incité de conflits qui ne
sont pas les nôtres et qui
structurellement nous pourront jamais
être les nôtres la France a un modèle de
défense singulier qui lui est propre
fruit d'une construction historique
gaulienne avant tout reposant sur une
autonomie stratégique française qui va
bien au-delà de la seule dissuasion
nucléaire et puis sa force dans le
sentiment profond que la France n'aurait
jamais dû perdre la drôle de guerre de
1940 n'aurait jamais dû connaître les
difficultés de l'expédition de Suez
n'aurait jamais à connaître de nouveau
les guerres d'Indochine ou d'Algérie
cette loi de programmation militaire
doit permettre non seulement de
poursuivre une réparation d'un outil de
défense et là s'abîmer dans le passé par
des politiques parfois courtermiste et
une forme de déni sur la réalité du
monde mais aussi transformer nos forces
sur des fonctions militaires concrètes
avec des objectifs opérationnels précis
cette programmation militaire ne propose
pas une rupture fondamentale avec notre
modèle historique au contraire elle
propose à sa manière d'y revenir dans sa
force conceptuelle initiale c'est-à-dire
dans sa capacité à s'adapter vite en
prenant en compte les défis du monde
actuel et donc comme menaces sécuritaire
actuelle ainsi qu'au technologique que
j’évoquais qui emmène avec eux
inévitablement des sauces stratégiques
ou tactiques dont le champ de
l'hybridité à cela s'ajoute la nécessité
d'articuler ces nouveaux domaines de
lutte autour de notre dissuasion et de
nos capacités expéditionnelles
permettez-moi de former donc le vœu
qu'on ne perde jamais de vue notre
modèle global de défense en attaquant
cette discussion parlementaire par de
nombreux détails techniques sémantiques
ou budgétaires qui peuvent toujours
avoir leur intérêt mais qui ne doivent
pas nous écarter de l'essentiel c'est à
dire l'exigence de cohérence et
l'efficacité opérationnelle notre modèle
d'armée qui reste et je le crois doit
rester une armée d'emplois c'est la
l'enjeu c'est la l'héritage que nous
avons reçu de nos anciens et que nous
devons protéger et laisser aux
générations futures ce que nous avons
souhaité faire primer dans cette loi de
programmation militaire pour les années
2024 à 2030 c'est notamment un impératif
de cohérence sur lequel je suis revenu
longuement dans nos travaux en
commission entre les livraisons
capacités les stocks de munitions de
pièces détachées le renforcement des
soutiens le maintien en conditions
opérationnelles et la formation qui
accompagne nos soldats sur le terrain
certains ont parfois le goût de la masse
de cible capacité à généreuses la
tentation d'acheter en masse des
équipements sans y intégrer leur vie
opérationnelle est un piège dans lequel
beaucoup de pays voisins sont tombés
nous-même avons parfois privilégié dans
le passé pour des raisons affichées
d'affichage ou industriels un nombre
d'hélicoptères livrés aux armées alors
qu'il aurait été préférable pour elle de
fixer le nombre d'hélicoptères en
capacité réelle de voler nous devons
apprendre de nos erreurs passées même si
je note chez certains une facilité ou
peut-être un refus d'obstacle à
considérer cette question dans son
ensemble une loi de programme n'est pas
qu'un seul tableau capacitaire tout cela
forme un tout logique efficace qui
s'appuie avant tout d'ailleurs sur le
tableau des contrats opérationnels la
vraie transformation est à chercher dans
ces fameux contrats opérationnels
détaillés dans le rapport annexé c'est
notre capacité demain à concevoir et à
dérouler des opérations Terre Mère cyber
espace informationnel cohésion national
de manière combinée c'est cela je le
crois la véritable leçon de la guerre en
Ukraine attiré pour nous-mêmes si nous
devons donner de la visibilité nous y
reviendrons à notre BITD si nous devons
la protéger la promouvoir la LPM doit
demeurer le moment où le Parlement doit
se pencher sur l'effectivité
opérationnelle ce qui a trop souvent
hélas était négligé par le pouvoir
politique et a pu placer nos forces en
situation de vulnérabilité face aux
menaces car précisément nous ne tenons
pas ces menaces pour illusoire ces choix
pour notre modèle de défense nationale
répondent à la volonté du Président de
la République exprimée lors de sa
première élection en 2017 mais aussi aux
besoins exprimés par nos forces armées
elles-mêmes depuis lors après un long
travail d'introspection demandée aux
États majeurs et à la DGA cet exercice
assez inédit n'a pas été sans difficulté
je tiens à remercier les chats
d'état-major le séma le DGSE le SGA ou
le DGA pour cette livrée à cet exercice
toujours délicat ils ont abouti au
projet de loi que je l'honneur de vous
présenter au nom du gouvernement et sur
lequel vous aurez à vous prononcer en
responsabilité mesdames et messieurs les
députés le Parlement a un rôle majeur
dans les choix stratégiques qui
assureront notre défense nationale au
cours des 7 prochaines années ce rôle a
d'ailleurs été largement renforcé par
votre commission de la défense avec
l'adoption de nombreux amendements avec
un avis favorable du Gouvernement ces
disposition relativement inédites
viendront renforcer le contrôle du
Parlement sur l'exécution
l'actualisation de cette programmation
notamment chaque année en amont de
l'examen des projets de loi de finances
qui restent on le sait les véritables
actes parlementaires pour engager
réellement les moyens
les débats que nous apprêtons à avoir
dans cette hémicycle seront donc aussi
un moment de vérité politique au sens
noble du terme modèle contre modèle en
quelque sorte où chaque sensibilité
pourra décliner les choix qu'elle
propose pour nos armées en fonction de
leur analyse portée sur la situation du
monde ce débat doit avoir lieu il est
sain il n'a rien de médiocre il
participe à la force du modèle français
il serait fou de soutenir qu'il y a
toujours eu un consensus sur tout cela
n'a d'ailleurs jamais été le cas depuis
1960 dans cet exercice l'examen du texte
en commission avec les nombreuses
amendements déposés par toutes les
sensibilités politiques représentaient à
l'Assemblée nationale m'a permis en tout
cas provisoirement de tirer quelques
premiers constats que je me permettrai
de partager ici quand il me semble
important pour notre défense nationale
mais aussi pour notre démocratie
certains me semblent tout d'abord
avancer dans une forme de flou je ne pas
dire masquer en tout cas ils n'ont pas
jusqu'à leur formalisé clairement leur
modèle d'alliance leur position sur la
dissuasion nucléaire et donc infinie sur
le modèle qu'il souhaite pour nos armées
gageons que ces deux semaines de débat
nous permettront de mieux le comprendre
donc enfin demeurent fidèle à leur
position historique depuis la première
loi de programmation militaire pour
certains en clarté en cohérence qu'il
faut reconnaître il n'en demeure pas
moins que le modèle d'armée proposé nous
exposerait immédiatement à des riches
imminent et que leur position repose
davantage sur une opposition au modèle
actuel sans pour autant dessiner
clairement un autre modèle pour nos
défendre d'autres encore ne voudraient
regarder ses débats que sur l'angle
budgétaire sont toujours en définir leur
finalité militaire bien qu'ils aient
directement ou parfois indirectement
jadis réduit les budgets de nos armées
quand ils étaient au responsabilités je
n'y reviendrai pas mais tenons cette
approche comme un avertissement pour
l'avenir nos dépenses militaires doivent
rester soutenables pour nos finances
public et être connecté à nos besoins
militaires réels d'abord et industriels
ensuite dans cet ordre c'est la
condition de la performance
opérationnelle dans la durée nous le
devons nous soldats d'autres enfin
estiment que nous dépensons trop sans
pour autant expliquer comment répondre
aux menaces à moins qu'il ne croit pas
en leur réalité ce qui me semble
dangereux et même naïf quoi qu'il en
soit mesdames messieurs les députés je
respecte et respecterai la position de
chacun et je m'efforcerai de défendre
cette loi de programme et les
convictions qu'elles portent la semaine
d'échange en commission a permis de
faire émerger des débats de fonds et de
qualité je le crois avec plus de 700
amendements discutés une centaine ont
été adoptées dont un tiers
issu des groupes de position c'est le
sens d'un débat sur un sujet aussi grave
et je forme le vœu que le débat dans
cette hémicycle plus au Sénat permettent
d'améliorer encore le texte de préciser
certains aspects ou bien encore de lever
éventuellement des ambiguïtés mesdames
et messieurs les députés prenons
maintenant quelques instants en amont de
la discussion des amendements pour
revenir sur les gros du texte des battus
en commission je veux d'abord revenir
sur les sujets sur lesquels nous ne
sommes pas tous d'accord je le disais
ils sont soit l'objet de dissension
historique entre les partis politiques
sous la 5ème République comme la
dissuasion nucléaire ou le niveau
d'appartenance ou non à l'Alliance
atlantique ou bien encore sur notre
modèle d'exportation d'armes soit
l'objet de dissension plus récente sur
les coopérations industrielles
européennes nous y reviendrons soit des
points de discussion sur la mise en
oeuvre de cette programmation sur lequel
j'ai répondu longuement en commission
notamment sur la construction de la
trajectoire budgétaire ou sur les choix
de priorité des investissements
capacités à proposer par ce texte pour
en défendre la cohérence et la
soutenabilité il y a donc dans cet ordre
d’abord la question de notre dissuasion
nucléaire
héritage que nous devons entre autres
général de Gaulle qui a permis d'offrir
à la France les moyens de sa vocation
nationale aux yeux du monde
le texte que je vous présente porte
l'ambition non seulement de défendre
notre diffusion nucléaire et de
continuer de la mettre en oeuvre seule
ce qui reste un défi industriel et
technologique mais aussi de préparer la
dissuasion de demain c'est le cœur de
notre souveraineté la voûte de la
défense de nos intérêts vitaux il
renonçait serait renoncer à notre
autonomie dans le concert des nations et
nous exposer inévitablement à des
risques plus forts ça doit programmation
la firme fermement pour aujourd'hui mais
aussi pour demain les choix que vous
prendrez ou non sont d'autant plus
importants que les programmes sont longs
à mettre en oeuvre 15 à 20 ans peuvent
s'écouler entre le moment au début un
programme et la date de mise en service
du vecteur ou du système d'armes aussi
cet LPM enclenche la modernisation de
nos sous-marins nucléaires lanceurs
d'engins 3e génération mais aussi la
modernisation des missiles des deux
composantes ces échelles de temps nous
obligent à nous projeter sur le long
terme en votant ses investissements vous
garantirez non pas notre protection mais
aussi celle de nos enfants et de leurs
enfants après eux
mesdames et messieurs les députés un
autre sujet a animé c'est le moment que
l'on puisse dire au débats en commission
il ne manquera pas de nous mobiliser
dans cette émission c'est bien sûr la
question de nos alliances c'est un sujet
de débat majeur entre ceux qui
souhaitent sortir purement et simplement
de l'OTAN d'autres de son organisme
intégré sont quand même un moment
intégrés ceux qui souhaitent abandonner
et non pas tout simplement encadré ce
que je distingue toute forme de
coopération militaire ou industrielle
avec nos partenaires européens et même
ceux qui veulent mettre un terme aux
exportations d'armement les questions
qui se posent à la représentation
nationale sont en définitive de savoir
ce que la France veut et même doit faire
seul et ce qu'elle veut ou doit faire à
plusieurs partant d'un principe que la
France n'est pas seule que ce n'est pas
selon moi sa vocation et que tout en
elle a su emmener avec elle d'autres
nations pour défendre des intérêts
communs ou partager nous l'avons encore
fait récemment au Soudan et
permettez-moi de rendre hommage à nos
militaires qui lors de l'opération SAG
ou la France grâce à ses capacités
expéditionnelles et son armée d'emploi a
pu évacuer seul et en premier c'est
ressortissants et ceux de ses alliés de
la ville de Khartoum soumises à un
fenouil mais le débat doivent également
mettre en relief nos choix pour
déterminer quand nous avons un avantage
à agir à plusieurs au sein d'une
alliance comme nous le faisons
actuellement en Roumanie en qualité de
nations cadre dans le cadre de la
mission aigle pourraient assurer les
frontières orientales de l'Alliance
atlantique nous devons aussi être en
mesure de déterminer quand nous
souhaitons agir en partenariat bilatéral
comme nous le faisons par exemple aux
Emirats arabes unis pour assurer par
exemple la sécurité du ciel enfin pour
déterminer quand nous devons agir en
européen parce que nous y avons un
avantage comme ce fut le cas notamment
au sein de la tasse force takuba mais
également pour certains programmes
industriels ou certaines missions de
sécurité maritimes pour faire ces choix
nous disposons de capacités qui nous
distinguent vis-à-vis de nos alliés
notre armée est une armée d'emplois je
le disais avec une culture
répétitionnaire capable d'intervenir
au-delà de ses frontières partout sur la
planète ce n'est pas le cas de toutes
les armées il faut bien le reconnaître
en clair les deux questions auxquelles
il faut répondre sont les suivantes pour
se débarbes votons pouvoir emmener les
autres ou doit-on accepter d'être emmené
par les autres et au-delà sans transiger
avec notre souveraineté quels sont les
menaces pour lesquelles une
interopérabilité une planification et
des entraînements communs sont
indispensables pour dissuader nos
compétiteurs sur les coopérations
européennes en matière industrielle
l'affirmation de nos intérêts doit être
rappelé peut-être même préciser je
l'entends et j'entends parfaitement que
le Parlement y soit davantage associé en
tout cas plus que par le passé la
discussion à venir nous permettra de
dégager je le crois et j'espère une
proposition satisfaisante sur la base
des amendements qui ont été déposés vous
connaissez nos options elles sont
claires et transparentes depuis 2017
néanmoins cela implique des moyens et
cette programmation militaire y répond
et c'est donc l'autre grand sujet qui
aussi animer nos discussions et sur
lequel je sais que vous serez nombreux à
revenir au cours de la semaine qui
concerne la trajectoire budgétaire
prévue par cette programmation militaire
je ne reviendrai pas sur le débat autour
des recettes extra budgétaires prévues
dans cet LPM celle-ci ont toujours
existé dans le passé elle n'avait jamais
suscité autant de débats la nouvelle
présentation les rend plus lisibles et
c'est une bonne chose la Commission a
souhaité créer un mécanisme de
sécurisation en cas de prévision non
réalisé c'est là aussi une bonne chose
et cela place désormais se débat
technique derrière nous même si je n'ai
jamais douté des prévisions élaborées
par les services du ministère je ven
néanmoins revenir sur les augmentations
historiques que nous vous proposons
depuis 2017 et jusqu'en 2030 lesquels il
faut le rappeler car cela n'a pas
toujours été le cas ont été exécutés à
l'euro près en 2017 le budget de nos
armées était de 32,3 milliards d'euros
cette année en 2023 le budget des armées
de 43,9 milliards d'euros c'est donc une
marge de mentation de 11,6 milliards
d'euros par rapport à 2017 sans compter
les crédits qui ont été votés en gestion
à cela il faut donc intégrer 1,5
milliards d'euros pour c'est encore
moins courant une surexcution budgétaire
en 2027 date qui intéresse beaucoup à la
fin du second quinquennat du président
de la République le budget des armées
sera 56 milliards d'euros soit une marge
d'augmentation de plus 23,7 milliards
d'euros il aboutira en 2030 à un budget
de 68,9 milliards d'euros or pension qui
aura donc plus que doublé le budget des
armées de la France en l'espace de deux
lois de programmation militaire j'ai
entendu certains regretter que le
principal de l'effort budgétaire
n'arriverait qu'en fin dès le PM c'est
donc faux chiffra la pluie cette
croissance est largement entamée par la
LPM actuellement en cours et l'essentiel
de l'effort aura été permis par
l'engagement du président de la
République et de cette majorité depuis
2017 je ne peux douter que celles et
ceux qui prétendent diriger le pays en
2027 voudront abîmer cet effort en tout
cas le Parlement aura à se prononcer
c'est le sens là aussi de l'amendement
que vous avez adopté en commission je
rappelle à la représentation nationale
que les marches annuelles d'augmentation
répondent certes à la soutenabilité de
nos dépenses publiques qui pourraient le
contester mais aussi sont définis en
fonction du besoin capacité physique en
crédit de paiement exprimé par nos
armées et de la capacité de nos
industriels à produire ses équipements
c'est le besoin physique aussi quand
certains proposent de basculer le gros
de l'effort en début de cette LPM cela
supposerait une solution magique pour
livrer en 12 ou 24 mois des grands
programmes d'équipements majeurs prévus
parfois sur une décennie ou bien
peut-être sans le dire souhaite-t-il
acheter du matériel sur étagère à
l'étranger ce qui est une position qui a
sa propre cohérence mais ce n'est pas
celle du gouvernement et ce n'est pas
l'ambition de porter d'ailleurs le
général de Gaulle d'avoir une armée
équipée par une industrie de défense
purement souveraine la trajectoire
budgétaire qui vous est proposée répond
elle à un impératif de soutenabilité et
de sincérité de nos dépenses militaires
sans quoi en fin de programmation
se reprocherait aux armées de ne pas
avoir été en mesure de dépenser les
crédits qui leur sont attribués cette
position envers un signal je le crois là
aussi de faiblesse et serait à bien des
égards non crédibles sur l'inflation les
nombreuses d'auditions que mission ont
permis je le crois à chaque
parlementaire de mieux comprendre les
nombreux mécanismes qui sont propres au
ministère des armées pour en limiter les
effets ces mécanismes n'existent
d'ailleurs pour aucun autre ministère
dans la République il suffit de
constater qu'aucun programme n'a pris de
retard en 2022 en 2023 voici une preuve
il en était
mesdames messieurs les députés les
travaux en commission ont enfin soulevé
des débats intéressants sur le
fonctionnement réel des armées et donc
de l'équilibre à trouver sur la cible
efficace en quelque sorte à atteindre
pour les équipements dont nous allons
doter nos armées je vais d'abord vous
dire très directement que lorsque l'on
double le budget des armées en 13 années
il sera difficile d'y voir des
renoncements puisque toutes les lignes
budgétaires augmentent pour les trois
armées leurs équipements seront très
largement renouvelés sur 7 ans ce sont
près de 200 milliards d'euros qui iront
vers le programme industriels cela
appelle des efforts majeurs en termes de
qualité on y reviendra de délai de
production de maîtrise des coûts et de
maintenance et de gestion des stocks
pour notre base industrielle et
technologique de défense pour autant il
ne s'agit pas d'investir sur toutes les
lignes à l'aveugle sans répondre à un
objectif clair qui est celui de la
cohérence du modèle d'armée que nous
souhaitons comme je l'évoquais en
introduction avec l'appui du chevet
amélior des armées sous l'autorité du
Président de la République j'ai donc
pris le parti de privilégier la
cohérence d'une capacité militaire dans
son ensemble par rapport à la seule
quantité des matériels c'est au fond
l'exigence de regarder dans le rapport
annexé autant le tableau des contrats
opérationnels que celui des équipements
capacitaires le dernier je le rappelle
n'étant au service que du premier il ne
servirait à rien d'avoir des centaines
de canons César dans des hangars sans
les artilleurs qui les font fonctionner
et les maintiennent en conditions
opérationnelles ces canons n'auraient
pas d'utilité sans les militaires qui
les engage les équipements qui les
accompagnent les pièces détachées les
systèmes d'information et de combat les
inf la peinture qui les abrite et les
munitions qui les armes cela aussi c'est
un retour d'expérience de l'Ukraine en
cela cette loi de programmation répond
au juste besoin opérationnel de nos
armées où il est grand temps de reparler
de brigade de division de corps d'armée
la cohérence opérationnelle c'est ce que
nous devons là encore à nos militaires
cette cohérence s'exprimera
particulièrement dans l'armée de terre
qui va pouvoir améliorer sa réactivité
et sa puissance dès 2027 les premiers
éléments les jetons national d'urgence
pourront au bout d'un mois être renforcé
au niveau d'une division autonome à deux
brigades avec ses appuis en étant en
mesure d'accueillir des contributions
alliées ces 12 à 15000 soldats entraînés
à la haute intensité et servant des
matériels scorpionisés modernes et
interconnectés seront appuyés par de
nouveaux moyens de franchissement les
premiers canons César de nouvelle
génération et encore plus hélicoptère au
dernier standard c'est là aussi plus
qu'une réparation mais une
transformation ainsi je retiens que
l'effort à conduire pour les soutiens
qui accompagnent nos militaires en vous
êtes nombreux à y être venu là aussi en
commission tel le service de santé des
armées le commissariat des armées les
techniciens en charge de la mise en
condition opérationnelle avec la
trajectoire d'investissement que nous
proposons n'est pas fondamentalement
remise en question même si certains
amendements peuvent venir proposer des
pistes d'efforts ou en tout cas des
clarifications nous les examinerons avec
attention il en va de même pour les
choix que nous vous proposons pour
l'innovation avec 10 milliards d'euros
sur la période pour que nos armées
soient au rendez-vous des sous
technologiques qui s'imposent à elle ces
investissements irrigueront par ailleurs
tout le tissu de l'innovation des écoles
d'ingénieurs aux grandes entreprises en
passant par les startups et les petites
et moyennes entreprises des amendements
utiles viendront éclairer les objectifs
que cela soit sur les drones de demain
le quantique l'intelligence artificielle
où les armes énergies dirigées c'est là
aussi une demande qui s'est exprimée en
commission les choix que je vous soumets
vise donc à permettre de préserver notre
modèle d'armée et à monter en puissance
sur des segments militaires
indispensables à notre souveraineté en
cohérence avec les capacités de
production de nos industriels
mesdames et messieurs les députés pour
conclure je veux enfin revenir sur les
sujets sur lequel nous nous sommes
accordés en tout cas je le crois au
cours de la semaine passée en commission
des amendements de la majorité comme des
oppositions avec souvent de belles
unanimités ont été adoptées pour
améliorer le texte que je vous propose
et j'en suis très heureux en premier
lieu je crois que nous sommes tombés
d'accord sur la préservation et même le
renforcement du lien sacré qui unit la
nation à ces armées se livrer de
l'article 11 du projet de Loire relatif
à l'ordre de la Libération qui en adapte
les fondements juridiques pour garantir
son avenir cela est vrai également de la
nécessité d'associer de plus en plus de
compatriotes notamment les plus jeunes
au commémoration les secrétaires d'État
auront l'occasion d'y revenir et plus
généralement de tout ce qui favorisera
chez nos concitoyens la reconnaissance
la considération le soutien nos forces
armées ou à nos anciens combattants et
qui est une forme courante paisible mais
vivante je le crois de patriotisme
concernant l'accompagnement nos soldats
et leurs familles les discussions
émanant de toutes les sensibilités en
commission se sont accordées pour
confirmer l'ambition de la programmation
militaire d'un densifier les efforts
entrepris dans le premier plan famille
le nouveau plan sera donc financé si
vous le votez ainsi à hauteur de 750
millions d'euros il sera entièrement
centré sur la vie familiale pour
compenser les absences et les
contraintes opérationnelles propres
statut du militaire en tout temps et en
tout lieu il engagera pour la première
fois des partenariats avec les
collectivités territoriales locales
volontaires pour accompagner nos soldats
et leurs familles dans leur recherche de
logement de solutions de scolarisation
de garde d'enfants et d'emploi pour les
conjoints cependant de la loi de
programmation militaire comprend en
outre un volet pour l'accompagnement des
blessés de thé de 169 millions d'euros
qui simplifiera l'accès aux droits la
reconnaissance et la réparation que la
nation doit assez soldats blesser pour
elle là aussi madame la secrétaire
d'État pourra y revenir
le deuxième sujet sur lequel nous avons
réussi à trouver une convergence lors
des débats en commission concerne la
politique salariale du ministère tous
ici vous partagez je le crois l'objectif
de mieux reconnaître les hommes et les
femmes du ministère militaire comme
civils sans opposé stérilement l'un des
militaire et l'indiciaire mais en
définissant un bon équilibre aussi un
effort ciblé sera conduit pour renforcer
la progression par les grises
indiciaires notamment pour les
militaires durant et les premiers graves
des sous-officiers dès 2023 puis je vous
l'annonce en 2024 pour les
sous-officiers supérieurs qui sont la
véritable colonne vertébrale en quelque
sorte de nos armées puis à partir de
2025 pour les officiers ces efforts
viendront en plus des efforts
considérables des gens entrepris sur
l'indemnitaire avec la nprm et en plus
de nouvelles mesures indemnitaires à
venir cette politique salariale couplée
à nos efforts pour la prise en compte
des familles des conditions de travail
de l'activité des soutiens permettra à
la fois de fidéliser et d'inciter les
militaires Durand et les sous-officiers
à prendre des responsabilités
c'est la promesse péritocratique que la
République doit assez soldats la
Commission a voté en ce sens plusieurs
amendements de la majorité mais aussi
des oppositions c'est une bonne chose et
je rappelle l'effort de 10 milliards
d'euros supplémentaires sur la période
pour la rémunération de nos personnels
avec une cible d'effectif permanente
inchangée à 275 000 personnes dans la
lignée de ces sujets les débats en
commission ont permis de partager la
nécessité de faire évoluer le format de
la réserve militaire pour remplir leur
mission nos armées comme Direction
générale de l'armement ont besoin de
s'appuyer sur une réserve plus forte
plus nombreuse mieux équipée mieux
formés mieux entraînés et surtout
pleinement intégré à l'active à
l'horizon 2035 nous visons un réserviste
pour deux militaires d'actives
c'est-à-dire peu ouprou 300 000
militaires dont 200 000 d’actives et
cent mille de réserve et s'il ratio a pu
faire l'objet de questions légitimes le
principe général et je le croiser déjà
le groupe de travail réunit cet hiver
avait été constructif sur un sujet nos
débats en commission ont été profitables
et plusieurs amendements pertinents sont
venus enrichir le texte enfin nos débats
en commission ont permis de faire
émerger un consensus et c'est heureux
concernant les conséquences qui au
réchauffement de la planète la
programmation militaire rectorat que
notre modèle d'armée devra intégrer dans
ses missions les effets du réchauffement
climatique de fait elles le font déjà
mais il y a de la force à l'instant dans
cette programmation militaire et je
pense en particulier à nous outre-mer
qui sont en première ligne avec la
montée des eaux et des événements
climatiques de plus en plus récurrents
et de plus en plus violents sans oublier
les enjeux liés à la pêche et légale ou
à leur paillage illégal pour ne citer
que ceci cela implique de renforcer nos
capacités de projection rapide en
outre-mer notamment pour mener à bien
ses missions mais aussi doter nos forces
de nouveaux segments technologiques
comme les drones ou des équipements de
liaisons de franchissement de
reconstruction qui nous permettront
d'être réactif et présent en cas de
catastrophe naturelle
mesdames et messieurs les députés les
débats que nous apprêtons à mener seront
assurément un moment de vérité devant
les armées devant les Français pour nous
allier et face à nos compétiteurs nous
ne seront pas d'accord sur tout mais il
est important que nous en tirions un
texte qui rassemble plus largement pour
préparer l'avenir de notre défense
nationale en permettant l'adoption de
cette programmation militaire pour cela
je souhaite que nos discussions en
séance permettent d'améliorer encore ce
texte pour nos soldats en ayant une
pensée pour les tuer et les blessés pour
notre nation car c'est Toi de
programmation militaire doit garantir
notre sécurité en assurant pour les sept
prochaines années et pour longtemps
encore le succès des armes de la France
je vous remercie
merci monsieur
le ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Michel Jacques rapporteur de la
commission de la Défense nationale et
des forces armées
mesdames Messieurs le ministre mesdames
Messieurs les Présidents mes chers
collègues à l'heure du retour de la
guerre en Europe de l'agression russe en
Ukraine de la stratégie de puissance de
la Chine ou encore de la multiplication
des menaces hybrides chacun d'entre nous
a conscience de l'importance du rôle de
nos armées pour faire entendre la voix
de la France
les mots du général de Gaulle sont
toujours d'actualité lorsqu'il disait la
France ne peut être la France sans la
grandeur
en sentant lui aussi avait été confronté
à des bouleversements géopolitiques et
technologique majeures décrié par
certains lorsqu'il avait choisi
d'investir massivement dans le nucléaire
militaire au détriment d'autres
investissements
l'histoire lui a donné raison
aujourd'hui mes chers collègues l'enjeu
est de continuer d'assurer à la France
son autonomie d'analyse de décision
d'action et de lui conserver son statut
de puissance d'équilibre et de nations
cadres
soyons les faire vents défenseurs de nos
valeurs soldats qui fidèle à leur
histoire et aux valeurs de l'armée
française sont prêts si la réussite de
leur mission les y oblige à aller
jusqu'au sacrifice suprême au moment où
je vous parle j'ai une pensée émue pour
nos blesser et nos morts pour la France
et je sais que chacun de vous s'associe
à cet hommage
derrière les trajectoires financières ou
capacitaires il ne faut jamais oublier
qu'il y a des hommes et des femmes
civils ou militaires qui sont la
première richesse de nos armées après
des décennies de sous-investissement la
dernière LPM a eu un impact positif pour
nos militaires dans leur quotidien et a
permis d'engager la modernisation
capacitaire
désormais après le temps de réparation
vient le temps de la transformation
cette transformation s'articule autour
de plusieurs axes le premier axe sa clé
de voûte c'est la modernisation de notre
dissuasion nucléaire dans toutes ses
composantes et dans une logique de
stricte suffisant la deuxième c'est que
nos armées soient prêtes à réagir de
manière décisive dans le cas d'un
éventuellement d'éventuels engagement
majeur pour ce faire il est essentiel de
consolider le soutien logistique le
maintien en conditions opérationnelle
mais également les capacités de haute
intensité je pense entre autres à
l'artillerie lourde à la défense solaire
au drone aux munitions et à nos blindés
ses capacités comme tous les équipements
de nos armées devront bénéficier du
meilleur des ruptures technologiques que
ce soit dans le cantique l'intelligence
artificielle l'hyper vélocité ou encore
la connectivité
le troisième axe de ce projet de loi
c'est de donner à nos armées la capacité
d'agir dans les champs hybrides le
spatial les fonds marins le cyber ou
encore les bulles informationnelles le
quatrième concerne nos territoires
d'outre-mer qu'il faut encore davantage
protéger face aux pressions de nos
compétiteurs
enfin le cinquième axe c'est notre
entrée dans une logique d'économie de
guerre qui nous permettra de gagner en
agilité de production en cas
d'engagement dans un conflit de haute
intensité
avant de conclure je souhaiterais
partager avec vous mon avis sur deux
points particuliers
premièrement la méthode je salue le réel
et approfondi réexamen des besoins de
nos armées qui a permis d'aboutir à une
trajectoire physico-financière adapté et
cohérente au regard de nos objectifs de
notre pays et des menaces
deuxièmement à rebours d'une culture
commandée par le principe de précaution
je me réjouis la revalorisation de
l'audace de la prise de risque en
réduisant les normes et en simplifiant
les circuits de décision
en conclusion mes chers collègues sachez
que j'ai pleinement confiance dans le
fait que nous ferons de cet examen un
débat constructif pour notre politique
de défense et que de chacun d'entre vous
sera guidé par la même boussole
l'intérêt supérieur de notre pays alors
Mesdames Messieurs mes chers collègues
bon débat et vive l'Armée française
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Sabine tiai
rapporteur pour avis de la commission
des lois constitutionnelles de la
législation et de l'administration
générale de la République
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres Madame
et Monsieur les rapporteurs
monsieur les présidents des commissions
excusez-moi chers collègues un chapitre
important de la LPM est consacrée à la
sécurité de système d'information la
menace cyber et protéiforme en constante
évolution et en augmentation tant qu'en
France qu'à l'échelle mondiale alors les
attaquants ne sont plus des seulement
des hackers isolés mais des acteurs
industriels capables de cibler des
secteurs d'activités entiers et de
s'attaquer au fonctionnement de nos
institutions le rapport d'Annecy sur
l'état de la cybermena sont 2022 relève
le nombre élevés d'attaques subies par
les acteurs institutionnels et
économiques en France avec 831 attaques
traitées au cours de et coller le
rapport souligne est également que si
les attaques de rangement si celles sont
contre les opérateurs réguliers publics
ou privés ont diminué la menace cyber
s'est déplacée vers des entités bien
moins protégées telles que les
collectivités territoriales les hôpitaux
et les petites et moyennes entreprises
que nous devons protéger
l'externalisation croissante et services
informatiques auprès d'entreprise de
service numérique accroît le risque
d'attaque avec 15 de ces entreprises
touchées en 2020 soit plus du double par
rapport à l'année précédente pour
maximiser l'efficacité de leurs attaques
les cyberatables désormais
principalement les sous-traitants et les
fournisseurs donc le niveau de sécurité
est souvent plus faible que celui des
opérateurs stratégiques leur permettant
ainsi d'accéder à des informations de
valeur
ces attaques ont des conséquences
financières importantes estimée à plus
de 100 milliards de dollars à l'échelle
mondiale selon l'OCDE elle perturbe la
continuité du service public et
compromettent la confidentialité des
données personnelles des patients dans
les hôpitaux par exemple c'est dans ce
contexte évolutif que s'inscrit la
présente loi de programmation militaire
et son chapitre 5 prend particulièrement
acte de cette évolution les articles 32
33 et 34 créent des nouveaux dispositifs
dans notre droit tandis que l'article 35
est un prolongement de disposition
introduites par la précédente LPM
l'article f32 permet à l'ancien en cas
de menace susceptible de porter atteinte
à la sécurité nationale de prescrire
plusieurs mesures graduelles affectant
les noms de domaine en particulier leur
blocage ou suspension
aux femmes de détection et de
caractérisation des attaques
informatiques l'article 33 permet à aux
agents de lentilles d'être destinataire
de données techniques non identifiantes
enregistrées sur les serveurs de
fournisseurs des systèmes de résolution
de noms de domaine et l'article 34
renforce les exigences de transparence
qui s'appliquent aux éditeurs de
logiciel en contraignant ces derniers à
informer l'annecy et leurs utilisateurs
en cas de vulnérabilité d'incidon
informatique grave enfin l'article 35
prévoit plusieurs dispositions visant à
renforcer les capacités de détoxion des
cyberattaques et l'information des
victimes en particulier il permet à
Nancy en cas de menace graves sur les
systèmes d'information des autorités
publiques et des opérateurs stratégiques
de mettre en oeuvre des dispositifs de
recueil de données d'autre part ce même
article rend obligatoire pour les
opérateurs de communication électronique
stratégique
la mise en place des systèmes de
détection des attaques informatiques
alors 91 amendements ont été discutés
ont commissions de loi et 46 d'entre eux
ont été adoptés provenant de l'ensemble
des groupes parlementaires qui ont
souhaité à mon don de texte il en
résulte un texte qui me paraît
aujourd'hui plus clair et équilibrée
sans avoir rien perdu de son utilité
opérationnelle un seul curseur nous a
guidé dans l'examen de ces quatre
articles l'équilibre nécessaire entre le
respect de nos libertés fondamentales
les intérêts de la sécurité nationale et
la préservation des intérêts de nos
entreprises françaises je vous invite
donc mes chers collègues à voter
largement ces articles nécessaires à la
protection de nos intérêts nationaux
tels amender par la commission des lois
et il est toujours beaucoup plus
difficile de garder un équilibre de
mettre le curseur au milieu que d'avoir
des
je dirais des opinions très tranchées
sur un ou l'autre aspect merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas gassiou
présente la commission de la Défense
nationale et des forces armées
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres
messieurs les présidents de commissions
mesdames madame et Messieurs les
rapporteurs et notamment le rapporteur
sur le fond de la Commission de la
défenseur Jean-Michel nous sommes réunis
en ce 22 mai mes chers collègues nous
sommes réunis dans ce 22 mai pour
l'étude de ce de cette loi de
programmation militaire et le PM 2024
2030 comme vous le savez c'est toi de
programmation militaire n'est pas une
loi ordinaire car les conditions de nos
capacités de défense dont dépend de
notre sécurité nos libertés nos
démocratie et même notre modèle social
mais aussi parce que l'arme les
militaires qui risquent notre vie pour
notre sécurité et enfin parce que
c'était le PM nous invite à regarder sur
le temps long là où souvent notre
société est plus orientée sur le temps
court c'était le PM prépare par exemple
et sous-marins nucléaires lançant qui
seront encore dans nos forces dans plus
de 60 ans
au-delà d'être une loi exceptionnelle
cette LPM arrive dans un contexte
exceptionnel celui de la du retour de la
guerre en Europe et également à l'heure
de profonde mutations technologiques qui
redistribue les cartes de la puissance
c'est pourquoi la Commission de la
Défense redouble des formes depuis
maintenant près de 6 mois pour préparer
l'étude de ce texte avec près de 90
auditions 5 missions d'information une
quarantaine de visites en France et à
l'étranger donc sur presque tous les
continents pour que ce texte rassemble
plus largement possible son examen s'est
fait de manière la plus ouverte possible
contrairement aux habitudes la
nomination d'un rapporteur a été
effectué autre que le président de la
commission et je remercie un nouveau
Jean-Michel pour son application
constante par ailleurs des articles ont
été délégués à la commission des lois et
merci à Sabine d'avoir pris ce le
taureau par les cornes sur les articles
32 à 35 comme elle l'a dit ils étaient
sont pas faciles à étudier et également
des commissions ce sont saisies pour
avis la commission des affaires
étrangères et la commission
par ailleurs un rapport a été demandé à
l'OPEX qui nous a été rendu mardi
dernier sur les retombées en termes
d'innovation technologique pour notre
pays et la commission des affaires
européennes c'est également saisie du
sujet et bien au-delà des assemblées de
notre assemblée les jeunes HDN ce sont
également mobilisés et quatre grands
débats publics ont été organisés et ont
réunit plus d'un millier de concitoyens
à Brest Pau Biscarrosse et Bergerac
cette ouverture c'est également traduit
en commission de la défense puisque par
rapport à la LPM de 2018 la Commission a
consacré deux fois plus de thoron débat
à étudier deux fois plus d'amendements
et on a adopté également deux fois plus
dont de nombreux d'ailleurs issus des
groupes d'opposition grâce justement au
175 amendements adopté des avancées
significatives ont déjà été obtenus
comme par exemple la sécurisation des 13
milliards d'euros de ressources extra
budgétaires des capacités de contrôle
renforcées pour le Parlement les
éligibilité de la taxe d'apprentissage
pour les établissements d'enseignement
technique et préparatoires militaire mes
chers collègues vous pouvez donc compter
sur l'engagement des commissaires à la
défense ces résultats nous les devons
aussi à notre ministre des Armées
Sébastien Cornu constamment présent
pendant l'ensemble de plus de 30 heures
des travaux en commission et qui est
aucune discussion pour défendre les
choix ambitieux de cette LPM mes chers
collègues ce qui nous réunit aujourd'hui
c'est la défense de notre pays pour cela
nous devons regarder le monde tel qu'il
est aujourd'hui tel qu'il le saurait en
2030 et non tel qu'on aimerait qu'il
soit le songe aussi fugace que trompeur
des dividendes de la paix à laisser la
place à une arène mondialisée où
l'intérêt prime sur le droit ou le
recours à la force est trop souvent
désinhibé c'est inquiétant paysage nous
a conduit à voter dès 2018 une LPM
2019-2025 pour réparer nos armées et
dont l'exécution s'est faite à l'Europe
ce qui je crois est assez inédit dans
l'histoire récente mais bien entendu on
n'efface pas 30 ans de
sous-investissement en 5 ans et c'est
pourquoi il ne faut poursuivre l'effort
de réparation est engagé la
transformation de nos armées tout en
gardant la maîtrise de nos de nos
dépenses publiques la LPM qui vous est
présenté aujourd'hui et donc un texte
d'équilibre répondant à cette double
responsabilité comme le disait le
président de la République avant de
Marsan c'est 413 milliards d'euros ne
présente ni confort rien que le
nécessaire nos débat nous permettront
sans doute de revenir dans le détail
dans les différents investissements et
sans doute continuer à améliorer
ensemble enfin si cette LPM est
exceptionnel et que nous pouvons compter
sur l'engagement sans faille de nos
soldats il est aujourd'hui nécessaire de
nous rappeler que la défense nationale
et l'affaire de tous dans un contexte où
l'hybridité des conflits devient la
règle et où chacun devient une cible il
est plus que jamais essentiel que toutes
les forces vives de la nation
entreprises que l'activité citoyen
contribue à leur niveau à une défense
globale c'est pourquoi nous devons
chacun agir pour développer une large
culture de défense dans notre pays alors
où la société française se questionne se
fracture parfois rappeler que la défense
et l'affaire de tous c'est aussi
affirmer que notre projet col lectif
républicain mérite qu'on y prenne soin
et qu'on le défende par la force si
nécessaire et c'est ainsi non seulement
avec une armée efficace mais également
tous engagé pour notre défense que nous
pourrons collectivement faire face au
désordre internationaux et contribuer à
la paix dans le monde c'est pourquoi je
vous souhaite à toutes et à tous de très
bons débats de fond je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
bourlant je présidente de la commission
des affaires étrangères
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre des Armées
monsieur le Président de la Commission
de la Défense nationale et des forces
armées Mesdames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous
entamons cet après-midi l'examen de l'un
des textes phares de notre législature
il est à raison de son objet absolument
fondamental pour notre République et
pour la nation il est aussi du fait de
son contenu en portant l'enveloppe
globale des crédits de notre défense à
413 milliards d'euros soit une
augmentation de 113 milliards sur la
période 2024
2030 je ne m'étendrai pas sur les
chiffres et que chacun juge en toute
objectivité la nuitée de la mission
budgétaire relative à la Défense va
passer de 47 milliards d'euros l'an
prochain à 69 milliards en 2030 soit une
augmentation de 46, 8%. notre pays
s'apprête à consacrer bientôt
2% sont produits intérieur brut à son
effort de défense ces arbitrages sont
nécessaires car la poursuite dans les
années à venir de l'effort de
régénération des capacités de nos armées
supposent le maintien de la trajectoire
budgétaire exigeante suivie avec succès
monsieur le ministre ces dernières
années
l'Ukraine nous rappelle nos devoirs et
nous appellent à la vaillance est-il
normal que dans l'Europe populante et
développée d'aujourd'hui ce soit encore
nos alliés américains qui fassent
l'essentiel du soutien à l'effort de
guerre de ce pays
quand je regarde ce que nous faisons
pour les autres je ne me désole pas loin
de là mais quand je regarde ce que nous
alliés outre-atlantiques font de leur
côté pour les Européens je ne me console
pas je me console d'autant moins que
comme la souligner le président de la
République l'engagement de nos alliés
américains aux côtés de l'Europe depuis
ce sinistre 24 février 2022 ne peut pas
être considéré comme aussi pérenne et
automatique que l'engagement interallié
de naguère non pas seulement parce que
les aléas de la politique américaine ne
nous mettent pas à l'abri d'une vague
isolationniste mais surtout et beaucoup
plus légitimement parce que d'autres
enjeux géopolitiques sollicitent les
Américains exigeant par la même que les
Européens de l'Ouest face la reprenne la
relève et cesse de considérer que l'art
sécurité et l'affaire des autres avant
d'être la leur
cette tentation n'a jamais été celle de
la France sous la Cinquième République
et elle est moins que jamais je me
réjouis de voir la constance de notre
engagement national en faveur d'une
dissuasion nucléaire destinée à protéger
nos intérêts suprêmes cette exigence de
vaillance passe par un développement
vigoureux notre effort budgétaire existe
de porter dès 2025 celui-ci à hauteur de
2% de notre produit intérieur votre
projet de loi monsieur le ministre est
très attendu il est par nos forces
armées c'est à dire par des femmes et
des hommes dont je rappelle qu'ils ont
délires délibérément choisi d'exposer
leur vie pour notre sécurité il est
aussi par nos partenaires internationaux
ainsi que par nos compétiteurs ou rivaux
stratégiques il est enfin par notre
assemblée qui se prépare depuis
plusieurs mois à ce rendez-vous
démocratique et politique important la
commission que j'ai l'honneur de prés à
légitimement souhaité apporter elle
aussi sa pierre à l'édifice je me
félicite que nos propositions pour que
ce soit mieux reconnue dans le respect
de nos engagements historiques avec nos
alliés le cadre européen de nos intérêts
et de notre outil de défense certains
points d'achamment subsistent néanmoins
notamment sur la participation de la
commission des affaires étrangères au
suivi au contrôle de la mise en œuvre
des engagements pris ainsi sur la portée
du rapport annuel sur les exportations
d'armement j'espère que nos débats en
séance permettront d'y apporter une
solution consensuelle
à travers la préparation de ce texte le
gouvernement prend en considération les
changements et les nouveaux défis qui se
présentent et il entend leur consacrer
d'importants moyens dans un contexte
d'incertitude accrue le maintien d'un
modèle d'armée complet et cohérent
constituent un impératif et nous nous
réjouissons de voir que c'est le vôtre
monsieur le ministre vous portez une
ambition réelle pour nos forces armées
et notre modèle de défense nous y
souscrivons et nous avons émis un évier
favorable à l'adoption de ce texte
moyennant quelques amendements l'examen
de ce projet de loi c'est jusqu'à
présent déroulé dans des conditions qui
honorent notre assemblée et que l'on
souhaiterait voir plus régulièrement
observé vous n'êtes pas étrangers à ce
qu'on ça monsieur le ministre et je vous
remercie de votre disponibilité et de
votre écoute pour ma part c'est avec
conviction que j'apporterai ma voix à
l'adoption d'un texte qui fait honneur à
nos forces armées et qui répond aux
besoins de la nation
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur
Pierre-Alexandre Anglade président de la
commission des affaires européennes
[Applaudissements]
la présidente monsieur le ministre
mesdames les ministres monsieur le
Président de la Commission de la Défense
et les forces armées Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs nous débattons
aujourd'hui dans un contexte
international qui donne une
responsabilité particulière à la France
à nos armées cela a été rappelé par le
rapporteur ce contexte c'est celui des
grands conflits internationaux parfois
d'autres intensité comme nous pouvons le
voir en Ukraine des tensions
géopolitiques exacerbées mais aussi du
renforcement de grandes puissances
autoritaires et d'une stratégie
clairement élaborée qui vise à remettre
en cause l'ordre international tel que
nous le connaissions depuis la fin de la
guerre froide et dans lequel la France
et l'Europe avait trouvé toute leur
place et qui nous permettait d'assurer
la paix alors que la guerre est de
retour en Europe et que les
nationalismes belliqueux redoublent
d'efforts le rôle de la France première
armée européenne et puissance
d'équilibre et d'assurer aux femmes et
aux hommes qui nous protègent les moyens
de le faire
en prévoyant 413 milliards d'euros
d'investissements sur 7 ans et en
portant notre effort de défense à 2% du
PIB cette loi de programmation militaire
permet à notre pays d'être à la hauteur
des défis de notre époque comme la
rappeler la revue stratégique de
novembre 2020 de l'Europe à l'Asie en
passant par le sel et le Levant et dans
l'Indo Pacifique les menaces sont
multiples et sa Greg plutôt qu'elles ne
se succèdent dans ce contexte notre
horizon doit être celui du renforcement
de nos armées mais aussi de l'astronomie
stratégique européenne cette loi de
programmation militaire nationale par
nature est un apport majeur à la
politique européenne de sécurité de
défense par sa puissance de projection
par le renforcement satisfaction
nucléaire à laquelle nous tenons par le
maintien en conditions opérationnelles
des équipements par notre maîtrise du
cyber du spatial et de l'ensemble du
spectre des éléments des guerres de
demain la France nations souveraine
participe à l'affirmation de l'autonomie
stratégique de l'Europe
ces dernières années nous avons
immensément progressé dans ce domaine de
la coopération structurée permanente à
la boussole stratégique à la création du
Fonds européen de défense nous avons
posé les bases de la défense européenne
et de son affirmation avec la guerre en
Ukraine une nouvelle étape a été
franchie puisque la facilité européenne
pour la paix a été mobilisé pour
financer l'effort de guerre ukrainien et
en former les soldats il faut saluer
l'investissement de la France dans cette
facilité européenne de paix tout cela il
faudra évidemment le poursuivre car ce
conflit en Ukraine qui fait rage depuis
plus d'un an maintenant nous enseigne
qu'il faut nous préparer avec nos
partenaires européens au retour des
conflits de haute intensité et à
l'accélération du recours à la très
haute technologie très haute technologie
en allant du cyber au quantique en
passant demain par l'intelligence
artificielle et très haute intensité en
Ukraine notamment avec le retour de
scène de guerre que nous croyons
appartenir au siècle passé de barmut à
Mario Paul qui nous rappelle évidemment
Verdun ou la somme c'est aussi pour cela
monsieur le ministre que la France a
raison de soutenir l'Ukraine et que je
salue encore les décisions annoncées par
le Président de la République sur la
formation des pilotes du Kenya ainsi que
sur l'entraînement et l'équipement de
plusieurs bataillons Ukrainiens de
dizaines de véhicules blindés et de
chars légers au-delà de ces annonces
notre soutien à l'Ukraine est efficace
car il est européen quand la France
forme des pilotes de chats Ukrainiens il
est efficace que d'autres pays européens
livrent des avions alors bien sûr
monsieur le ministre la rappeler nous ne
sommes pas tous d'accord sur nos
alliances internationales nos
partenariats nos coopérations mais si la
France est forte dans le monde c'est
aussi parce qu'elle est au cœur d'une
Europe qui se renforce une Europe de
plus en plus indépendante parce qu'elle
développe des coopérations des
partenariats notamment industriels avec
nos partenaires allemands italiens
espagnols belges contrairement à
certains mensonges il n'est pas question
de dissoudre l'armée française dans un
ensemble européen bien plus large mais
bien d'imaginer ensemble une coopération
opérationnelle d'intervention
utile sur le terrain à la protection de
nos intérêts car si demain l'un de nos
grands partenaires doit regarder
ailleurs comme ça déjà été le cas par le
passé nous devons être en mesure d'agir
avec les Européens à l'intérieur de
l'OTAN ou en dehors de l'Alliance et si
nécessaire d'assurer les capacités de
commandement qui permettront de mener
ensemble avec nos partenaires une
opération d'ampleur comme la rappeler le
président de la République sur le
terrain nos forces armées savent bien
que le levier européen est un levier de
puissance pour la France les efforts
européens permettent ainsi aux femmes et
aux hommes qui nous défendent de se
déployés conjointement avec leurs frères
dames européen sur pas moins de 9
théâtres d'opérations la force takuba en
étant une illustration importante avec
cette loi de programmation militaire
nous renforçons le modèle unique et
éprouvé de nos armées il n'y a qu'à voir
la reconnaissance mondiale tant parmi
les Européens que parmi nos partenaires
de l'OTAN de au Soudan et cela a été
rappelé avec cette loi de programmation
militaire nous préparons l'avenir
technologique qu'il soit question de
cyber ou de spatiale ainsi que de que
les nouveaux champs de confrontation des
puissances en Indo-Pacifique face à une
Chine qui ne fait plus mystère de sa
puissance la France tient son rang grâce
à son armée et à ses territoires de
outre-mer avec cette loi de
programmation militaire en fin madame la
Présidente nous faisons acte de
souveraineté tant nationales que
européenne en renforçant notre défense
et en nous donnant à nos armées les
moyens de notre puissance je vous
remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Louise Morel
rapport pour observation de la
commission des affaires européennes
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre monsieur
le président de commission madame et
Messieurs les rapporteurs mes chers
collègues c'est la première fois que la
commission des affaires européennes est
saisie pour observation sur une loi de
programmation militaire s'exprimer à
cette tribune sur ce sujet avec un
regard européen et donc un exercice
inédit la loi de programmation militaire
vise à définir les orientations
stratégiques de la Défense nationale
pour les années 2024 à 2030 et a procuré
aux armées les moyens matériels et
financiers nécessaires pour atteindre
les objectifs fixés
l'adoption anticipée d'une nouvelle loi
de programmation militaire tient à
l'évolution rapide du contexte
stratégique l'invasion de l'Ukraine
vient en premier à l'esprit mais la
revue nationale stratégique de novembre
2022 dressait déjà un état général
inquiétant de la situation mondiale avec
une compétition plus intense entre
grande puissance
et une augmentation rapide des budgets
militaires russes et chinois la France
seule peut difficilement relever
l'ensemble de ces défis et l'Europe a
joué jusqu'à présent en rôle de second
plan au niveau mondial l'OTAN et les
États-Unis restent les protecteurs de
notre continent or si l'Europe ne peut
assurer seul sa propre défense son poids
dans le monde s'en trouvera réduit force
est de constater que l'invasion de
l'Ukraine a été un électrochoc si
l'Europe c'est fortement mobilisée pour
aider l'Ukraine contre l'agression russe
cet effort sans précédent a également
révélé les limites de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne qui doit se
construire face à deux contraintes la
première tient à ce que la défense reste
une prérogative nationale intimement
liée à la souveraineté des États et dont
la mutualisation reste limitée par le
niveau d'intégration politique de notre
continent c'est pourquoi l'Europe de la
Défense s'est concentré suis le traité
de Lisbonne sur le renforcement de
l'industrie de défense et sur la
mutualisation de moyens en vue de
mission encore limitée dans leur format
et leur finalité toutefois la seconde
contrainte concerne l'Europe de la
défense celle-ci se construit d'autant
moins vite que la défense du continent a
été confiée depuis 1949 à l'OTAN le rôle
prépondérant des États-Unis en son sein
a conduit beaucoup d’états européens à
ne concevoir leurs moyens militaires que
comme une contribution à la défense
collective du continent coordonnée par
l'Alliance et assurer principalement par
les États-Unis
l'Union européenne a toutefois fait
petit à petit départ vers la coopération
européenne en matière de défense depuis
la mise en place de la politique de
sécurité et de défense commune en 1999
ce sont plus de 40 missions civile et
militaires qui ont eu lieu au service
d'une politique étrangère qui dispose
désormais de moyens d'intervention
encore limité mais de plus en plus
significatif d'autre part la création de
l'Agence européenne de défense en 2004
du Fonds européen de défense en 2016 de
la coopération structurée permanente en
2017 de la facilité européenne pour la
paix en 2021 témoigne d’étape franchie
vers la construction d'une défense
intégrée même si l'étape des physiques
décisive de l'autonomie n'a toutefois
pas été franchie
cette loi de programmation militaire
bien qu'elle ne dispose pas de
disposition directement liées à la
coopération européenne contribue
cependant de façon indirecte à cet
effort le rapport annexé auquel renvoie
l'article 2 du texte fait état de
l'importance comme des limites des
coopérations au service de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne de plus la
contribution française à la défense
européenne est avant tout une question
de capacité il faut le rappeler la
défense collective de l'Europe qu'il
s'agisse de l'OTAN ou de la coopération
européenne en matière de défense repose
d'abord sur l'agrégation de force
nationale et non sur la constitution
d'une véritable armée multinationale
cette loi va toutefois faire avancer le
sujet de la coopération européenne en
portant les dépenses militaires à 2% du
PIB en 2030 elle permet à la France de
maintenir son rang en Europe au moment
où nos partenaires européens augmentent
leur budget elle renforce nos moyens
dans des domaines peu visibles mais
cruciaux achat de munitions de pièces
détachées entraînement et réactivité
je vous remercie
[Musique]
j'ai reçu de Monsieur André Chassaigne
et des membres du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine lupet une
motion de rejet préalable dépose un
application de l'article 91 alias 5 du
règlement la parole est à Monsieur
Fabien Roussel
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues
décidez d'engager 413 milliards d'euros
pour nos armées pendant les 7 prochaines
années est un sujet extrêmement sérieux
important et c'est d'ailleurs pour cette
raison que nous avons déposé une motion
de rejet pour la simple et bonne raison
que nous demandons solennellement que
ces choix fassent partir d'un large et
grand débat avec tous nos concitoyens
toute la société bien au-delà de notre
assemblée d'abord parce que cette loi de
programmation militaire implique une
stratégie au service de l'OTAN que les
Français doivent connaître vous défendez
monsieur le ministre vous venez de le
dire une autonomie stratégique pour la
France où est cette autonomie
stratégique depuis que la France a
rejoint le commandement intégré de
l'OTAN nous souhaitons pour notre part
nous retirer de ce commandement intégré
et retrouvé pleinement notre autonomie
stratégique si cher au gaulliste et aux
communistes et nous sommes fidèles à
cette histoire-là ensuite
parce que ce budget va atteindre 69
milliards d'euros par an en 2030 69
milliards d'euros à l'heure où votre
gouvernement demande énormément
d'efforts à nos concitoyens y compris en
leur demandant de travailler plus pour
financer notre système de retraite 69
milliards ce qui en fera et cette inédit
sous la Cinquième République le premier
budget de l'État devant celui de
l'éducation nationale pour lever tout
ambiguïté sur la position des élus
communistes et du groupe GDR nous sommes
très attachés à l'indépendance et à la
souveraineté de la France en matière de
défense et même d'industrie de défense
nous sommes de ceux qui voteront toutes
les dépenses permettant d'augmenter ses
moyens les moderniser permettre à nos
soldats de s'entraîner de se protéger
d'être les plus efficaces sur le terrain
la défense nationale ne se négocie pas
elle doit être forte et efficace je
tiens d'ailleurs à rendre hommage aux
soldats disparus ces dernières années et
avec eux à toutes celles et ceux qui
sont prêts à faire le sacrifice ultime
de leur vie pour permettre à chacun
d'entre nous de vivre libre dans notre
République et c'est d'ailleurs parce que
nous sommes attachés à cette
souveraineté que nous contestons vos
choix d'investir autant d'argent dans
une armée de projection symbolisée par
ce porte-avions nouvelle génération à 10
milliards d'euros
alors je vous pose la question monsieur
le ministre a-t-on les moyens de se
payer à la fois une armée de
projection des terrains lointains
t de tout nos territoires et la
protection de tous nos concitoyens sur
tous les continents nous ne le pensons
pas et nous tenterons de le démontrer
pendant les débats de même est-il
incontournable d'investir 54 milliards
d'euros dans la dissuasion nucléaire
dans l'escalade nucléaire alors où tout
devrait être fait pour que l'arme
nucléaire disparaisse de la planète dans
un élan commun et multilatéral de toutes
les puissances nucléaires j'y reviendrai
mais surtout
surtout j'aimerais dire ici qu'aurions
nous fait nous en responsabilité à votre
place sur un sujet d'une telle
importance pour la nation
bien sûr nous aurions mis tous les
moyens pour rattraper des retards pris
ces dernières années mille et les moyens
en face des besoins de nos armées en
tenant compte du contexte de guerre et
de tension internationales nous aurions
augmenté le budget des armées mais il
n'aurait pas doublé pour autant la
question centrale est d'abord de définir
les objectifs que nous fixons à nos
armées les priorités pour nous c'est
d'abord se donner les moyens d'avoir une
armée dédiée à la défense de nos
territoires nationales et à la
protection de nos concitoyens et de nos
ressortissants ou qu'ils se trouvent
dans le monde
c'est de nous protéger de toute attaque
venant de pays extérieurs comme du
terrorisme c'est d'avoir un lien fort
entre l’armée et la nation c'est d'être
capable de sécuriser l'immense espace
maritime qui est le nôtre le deuxième
plus important au monde
c'est d'anticiper les attaques cyber et
de protéger les espaces de toutes
militarisation enfin pour éviter les
guerres et les conflits nous préférons
investir nous dans la diplomatie plutôt
que de l'affaiblir comme c'est le cas
depuis trop longtemps
nous plaiderons toujours pour la
recherche de la paix pour le respect du
droit international et pour un soutien
sans faille aux actions impulsées par
les Nations Unies
et nous défendrons toujours notre
indépendance en matière de défense tout
en travaillant à désaccords de sécurité
collective sans hégémonisme ni
suprématie de quelques pays que ce soit
je pense bien sûr à la domination des
États-Unis au sein de l'OTAN
notre longue histoire le prouve et nous
communiste nous ne sommes pas des naïfs
au périls qui menaçait notre pays les
communistes ont toujours su répondre
présents pour le défendre pour résister
à l'oppresseur les armes à la main c'est
pourquoi nous souhaitons que notre armée
dispose des meilleurs matériels des
nouvelles technologies que nos soldats
soient bien équipés bien formés mieux
rémunéré et je le conseille il y a sur
ces différents points des avancées
positives dans cette loi de
programmation militaire il faut le
reconnaître mais aujourd'hui le
président de la République nous dit
qu'il faudrait avoir une guerre d'avance
et tirer les conclusions de ce que notre
époque porte en gem
et bien nous nous craignons au contraire
qu'avec cette loi de programmation
militaire d'avoir une paix de retard si
rien n'est fait politiquement pour
désarmer les conflits et travailler à la
sécurité collective des nations à ce
titre vous faites reposer notre
politique de défense sur la dissuasion
nucléaire oui c'est une différence
historique entre nous mais vous savez
nous avons acté ce choix depuis mais
surtout aujourd'hui notre désaccord dans
cette loi de programmation militaire
c'est le niveau de dépenses que vous
engagez mais c'est énorme et les
Français doivent le savoir
même si c'est écrit nulle part et c'est
un sujet c'est un sacré problème pour la
transparence la seule indication que
vous avez donnée à l'oral c'est cette
part de 13% de la loi de programmation
militaire consacrée à la dissuasion
nucléaire c'est une somme évaluée par
tous à 54 milliards d'euros sur 7 ans
c'est un niveau de dépenses inédit
alors quand est-ce que nous aurons un
véritable débat avec les Français sur
une politique décidée dans les années 60
par le général de Gaulle et qui n'a
jamais été rediscuté depuis jamais quel
bilan pouvons-nous tirer quel est
l'utilité réelle de cette dissuasion à
l'échelle du monde toutes ces questions
sont légitimes d'autant plus que la
priorité absolue donnée au
renouvellement de nos armes nucléaires
non seulement vampirisme le reste des
dépenses de la loi de programmation
militaire j'y reviendrai mais va
également à l'encontre de nos
engagements internationaux en la matière
en ratifiant le Traité de Non
proliférations nucléaires le TNP en août
92 notre pays c'est en effet engagé je
cite à poursuivre de bonnes foi des
négociations relatives à la cessation de
la course aux armements nucléaires et au
désarmement nucléaire encore ce week-end
monsieur le ministre à l'issue d'un G7
qui s'est tenu à Hiroshima la France
avec les autres est un membre s'est
engagé je cite à nouveau je cite
approfondir les efforts de désarmement
et de non proliférations visant à
atteindre l'objectif
ultime d'un monde sans arme nucléaire
mais je signe cette déclaration
alors quelle France faut-il croire celle
qui approuve les déclarations à plants
désarmement nucléaires que nous
partageons ou bien celle qui dépense des
dizaines de milliards pour renforcer son
arsenal pour notre part nous pensons
qu'il faut à minima respecter les termes
du traité de non prolifération
nucléaires
et si nous ne sommes pas favorables à un
désarmement unilatéral je l'ai dit je le
redis si publiquement nous ne sommes pas
favorables un désarmement unilatéral
pour autant nous estimons que la France
en tant que membre permanent du Conseil
de sécurité un rôle diplomatique majeur
à jouer pour contribuer à écarter la
menace nucléaire et c'est la raison pour
laquelle nous souhaitons que notre pays
participe comme État observateur aux
réunions du traité sur l'interdiction
des armes nucléaires sous l'égide des
Nations Unies sur le sujet du nucléaire
nous vous demanderons enfin de soutenir
nos amendements demandant réparation aux
victimes des essais nucléaires victimes
civiles ou militaires des zones
contaminées de Polynésie ou d'Algérie
j'en viens maintenant à cette volonté de
bâtir une armée de projections capables
d'intervenir vite et en tout point de la
planète et surtout le problème toujours
sur la domination de l'OTAN c'est la
culture expéditionnelle monsieur le
ministre là aussi ne pensez-vous pas
qu'il y a besoin d'un bilan de ces
opérations menées depuis 20 ans
seul ou au sein d'alliance ces
interventions non réglé aucun des
problèmes posés à commencer par celui du
terrorisme en Afrique elles ont au
contraire entraîné une déstabilisation
politique économique et sociales une
dissémination d'armes et de munitions
comme en Libye ou en Afghanistan ces
échecs stratégiques ont contribué à
créer une certaine rancœur à l'égard de
nos forces comme récemment au Sahel et
les qualités exceptionnelles de nos
soldats auxquels je veux rendre hommage
encore ne sont bien sûr pas en cause ce
sont la stratégie et la doctrine
d'emploi des forces qui sont posées oui
il est plus que temps d'abandonner ce
vieux modèle d'armée de culture
expéditionnaire non seulement parce
qu'il exalte de tristes relents
néocolonialiste mais aussi parce qu'il
se perpétue au détriment des missions
essentielles de protection du territoire
national
la clé de voûte nucléaire ne protège pas
des attaques terroristes sur notre sol
tout comme elle ne protège pas des
conflits hybrides ou la frontière entre
civils et combattants entre monde réel
et virtuel est absent
nous aurons aussi une grande décision à
prendre a-t-on besoin d'un porte-avion à
propulsion nucléaire de nouvelles
générations qui mobilisera au moins 10
milliards d'euros nous ne le pensons pas
et nous ne voterons pas ces crédits nous
pensons qu'il y a mieux d'affaires quand
la défense opérationnelle de notre
territoire révèle des lacunes criante et
je pense notamment à notre surface
maritime pour lesquelles les renforts
annoncés restent insuffisants il nous
semble en effet urgent de préférer un
modèle d'armée taillé pour protéger nos
concitoyens en Océanie dans l'océan
Indien en Amérique ou en Amérique ou en
Europe c'est tellement vrai que le poids
excessif des dépenses liées à la
dissuasion nucléaire ou à ce porte-avion
vous contraint monsieur le ministre a
opéré des glissements ou des reports de
crédit important sur des programmes
majeurs voire carrément des coupes
claires et tous les bancs de l'Assemblée
à parler de ces coupes claires dans
certains crédits du côté de la marine si
importante pour la défense de nos hommes
économiques exclusives la cible 2030 des
frégates de défense et d'intervention
passent ainsi de 5 à 3 unités celle du
système de drone aérien pour la marine
de 15 à 8 celle des avions de
surveillance et d'intervention maritimes
Albatros de 13 à 8 je ne veux pas
allonger la liste d'autant que cela a
déjà le Mans est évoqué en commission
enfin
notre modèle industriel de l'armement
trop précaire trop dépendants d'autres
pays ou encore de fonds de pension
privée étrangers doit être questionné
même si nous partageons le principe de
coopération avec d'autres pays européens
je le dis nous défendons le principe
d'un pôle public de l'armement garant de
notre souveraineté capable de s'appuyer
sur une participation de l'État dans ses
principales entreprises
nous voulons aussi garantir le statut et
les conditions de travail des ouvriers
d'État indispensables pour répondre aux
besoins de nos armées
vous l'avez compris nous plaidons pour
un modèle d'armée bien différent du
vôtre délivrer des obligations de
rentabilité industrielle tournée
exclusivement vers la protection de la
nation de nos territoires et ceux de nos
voisins européens dans le cadre de
traiter européen de sécurité collective
un modèle qui permettrait de renforcer
une France crédible pour la paix et une
France libre et bien sûr libérée des
influences du commandement militaire
américain de l'OTAN bien que ce texte
permet quelques avancées je vous l'ai
dit notamment aussi je le dis ici sur
les conditions de vie d'indemnisation
des soldats
et sur la reconnaissance de la mention
mort pour la France pour les résistants
étrangers fusillés pendant la Seconde
Guerre mondiale ou encore la
pérennisation de l'Ordre de la
Libération
les députés du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine propose en
l'état de rejeter ce texte et de
remettre l'ouvrage sur le métier en
commençant par un large débat avec les
Français sur les choix de la France en
matière de paix et de sécurité je vous
remercie
je vous remercie
sur le vote de la motion de rejet
préalable je suis saisie par le groupe
Renaissance et par le groupe gogemocrate
et républicaine d'une demande de scrutin
public le scrutin est annoncé dans
l'enceinte de l'Assemblée nationale
il se mittre
oui madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Fabien Roussel bon je voulais indiquer
nombreuses reprises en commission comme
d'ailleurs à de nombreuses reprises dans
cette émission le Parti communiste
français le mérite de la cohérence
depuis 1960 avec des positions qui sont
affirmées notamment contre la dissuasion
nucléaire je l'avais aussi précisé en
1960 cette conduite était aussi dictée
par Moscou vous qui êtes attentif à
l'autonomie stratégique française il
faut quand même rappeler que
malheureusement c'est la diplomatie
soviétique à l'époque qui envoyait ses
consignes aux parties communistes
français que désormais Monsieur Le Coq
je fais juste un peu d'histoire ça fait
du bien tout le monde que désormais
évidemment vous le faites en
connaissance de cause désormais et dans
le fondement de vos convictions
plusieurs peut-être commentaires sachant
que certains aspects ont largement été
traités lors de la discussion générale
ou lors du travail en commission moi
monsieur le député je n'opposerai jamais
les budgets militaires pour la sécurité
de la nation avec les un budget sociaux
pour la sécurité sociale de la nation et
si vous convoquez l'esprit 1945 l'esprit
du Conseil National de la Résistance il
est intimement lié entre les deux nos
posons jamais la sécurité collective de
la nation française et les mécanismes de
solidarité c'est ce que les résistants
qu'ils étaient communistes ou qu'ils
étaient gaullistes justement je
reviendrai mais justement nous ont
laissé en héritage et d'ailleurs les
chiffres sont têtus comme aurait dit un
camarade que vous connaissez bien
puisque les budgets annuels militaires à
terme arriveront à 69 milliards d'euros
là où les budgets sociaux de la nation
représentent 840 milliards d'euros par
an là aussi les chiffres sont têtus et
je pense qu'il ne faut pas
contre-informer notre opinion publique
et nos concitoyens après il peut y avoir
des débats ils sont nobles sur le niveau
de répartition mais ne montons pas les
budgets de la nation les uns contre les
autres c'est comme ça qu'on a fait
bilanation et c'est comme ça justement
qu'on abîme l'acceptabilité sociétale de
ce que font nos forces armées au service
de la sécurité collective 2 vous nous
dites monsieur le député monsieur le
Premier skata qu'il faut le rejet de ce
texte et en même temps qu'il faut qu'il
y ait un débat vous avez été candidat à
l'élection présidentielle depuis 1962
l'avènement de la dissuasion a amené le
général de Gaulle à modifier la
Constitution au titre de ce coup d'état
permanent dans lequel justement le
président de la République était élu au
suffrage universel direct parce qu'il y
a la force de frappe donc le débat il a
eu lieu malgré tout à chaque élection
présidentielle et d'ailleurs ça n'a pas
profité à certains tant parfois il y
avait une forme de trouble sur le niveau
d'alliance des uns et des autres deux
pardon on est devant la représentation
nationale le général de Gaulle et les
députés communistes ont voulu les lois
de programme en 1960 en 1964 et jusqu'à
aujourd'hui n'empêchez pas le débat en
votant cette notion de rejet puisque
précisément les 35 heures de débats en
commission les 700 amendements les
quelques 1500 qui ont été déposés pour
débattre pendant 15 jours ici dans cette
enceinte puis demain au Sénat et
j'imagine dans la commission mixte
paritaire ensuite entre vous nous
permettra de le et donc rejeter le texte
c'est rejeter évidemment l'ensemble des
amendements qui sont déposés dont des
amendements que vous avez vous-même
déposés et qui viennent compléter
utilement le texte ou sur d'autres épées
je ne suis pas d'accord mais qui
viennent en tout cas défendre vos
opinions et vos convictions 3 le
porte-avion le débat a déjà eu lieu
notamment avec le groupe Europe Écologie
Les Verts il aura de nouveau lieu ce
n'est pas qu'un instrument de puissance
un instrument de sécurité ne donnant pas
l'impression que le groupe ironaval
n'est là que pour défendre des intérêts
maritimes qui seraient lointains qui
serait détachés de la sécurité de la
nation française mesdames et messieurs
les députés quand on a des territoires
d'outre-mer par définition on doit avoir
une marine complète et le groupe
aéronaval en fait partie quand on est un
pays qui est important malheureusement
si j'ose dire beaucoup d'hydrocarbures
et qui exportons beaucoup de matières
premières agricoles on a besoin de
s'assurer des libertés maritimes et des
libertés de circulation de circulation
maritimes sur la mer Méditerranée sur
Suez sur hormoz là aussi vous êtes
contradictoire faudrait donc se remettre
intégralement au groupe aeronaval des
États-Unis d'Amérique présents en
Méditerranée et donc abandonner nos
propres outils d'intervention qui sont
propres à la nation française donc moi
je défends le groupe aéronaval parce que
justement c'est un des moyens de ne pas
dépendre des autres puissances et
singulièrement monsieur le député
monsieur le Premier secrétaire de la
puissance américaine et donc là aussi on
peut pas dire tout et son contraire là
où je suis en désaccord avec vous c'est
que habilement vous nous expliquez
peut-être pour certaines sensibilités
que avec vous les budgets aurait
augmenté mais certainement pas doublés
ça nous donne pas une cible très précise
vous en conviendrez et puis de l'autre
vous nous dites plus de dissuasion
nucléaire sortie de l'OTAN et
nationalisation de la BTD ce qui
immanquablement modifie le format
d'armée puisque la sortie de l'OTAN et
la fin de la dissuasion nucléaire je
donnerai sur la dissuasion mais
d'ailleurs le commandement intégré on
aura l'occasion d'y revenir mais c'est
un échange qu'on a déjà eu aussi avec un
certain nombre de parlementaires ici
présent le commandement intégré le temps
de 1966 n'est plus le même
qu'aujourd'hui mais je pourrais en tout
cas y revenir en tout cas à la fin de la
dissuasion voûte nucléaire qui
permettent de défendre nos intérêts de
protéger nos intérêts vitaux sortez du
commandement intégré de l'OTAN et
nationalisation de la BITD ne faisons
pas croire aux françaises aux Français
qui nous regardent que ça coûterait
moins cher que 69 milliards d'euros par
an c'est une modification profonde de
notre modèle d'armée qui entraînerait
des dépenses qui sont beaucoup plus
importantes donc là aussi il faut que
vous assumiez que ce modèle est un
modèle qui a bien des égards peut coûter
beaucoup plus cher et là aussi je tiens
à votre disposition les éléments de
comparaison de d'autres puissances qui
bien que dans le temps n'ont pas la
dissuasion nucléaire et un manquablement
depuis les années 60 ont un impact sur
notre format d'armée par ailleurs il y
aurait aussi une forme de mensonge
devant la nation française à ne pas
documenter le fait que la somme de 413
milliards d'euros qui est certes est
considérable vous avez raison de le dire
c'est beaucoup d'argent d'autres parfois
nous ont expliqué c'était pas assez on
trouvera un point d'équilibre mais est
lié au saut technologique de la
militarisation de nouveaux espaces vous
nous dites il faut avoir une paix
d'avance
mais comment ne pas voir que cette paix
d'avance elle passe par une stratégie
spatiale elle passe par une stratégie
cyber elle passe par une stratégie sur
les fonds sous-marins elle passe par une
stratégie en matière d'innovation sur
lequel vos collègues de la France
insoumis sont suffisamment revenus en
commission et qui nécessairement
nécessite des sommes importantes donc il
n'y a pas de schéma dans lequel
malheureusement les choses peuvent
coûter moins cher demain et ça je pense
qu'il faut qu'on s'accorde là dessus
sinon évidemment on peut perdre une
partie de l'adhésion de nos concitoyens
et concitoyens sur évidemment les
dépenses militaires bon sur la
dissuasion nucléaire on aura l'occasion
de dire venir il y a de nombreux
amendements c'est néanmoins un sujet clé
le débat a bien lieu il a eu lieu en
commission il doit continuer d'avoir
lieu je pense qu'il ne faut pas jouer
sur les mots entre lutter contre la
prolifération et interdire les armes
nucléaires qui est évidemment un piège
qui nous est tendu donc à la fois vous
nous dites pas de désarmement unilatéral
mais en même temps vous nous dites si
nous avions été à votre place qu'un seul
plaise
mais en clair si vous étiez ministre de
la défense d'un gouvernement avec un
président de la République
issu de la nupaise pour bien comprendre
je serai donc sénateur de l'opposition
et quelques pies vous nous auriez
proposé monsieur le député une copie
dans lequel il y aurait des lignes à
zéro sur la dissuasion nucléaire des une
copine dans lequel les lignes n'auraient
aucune augmentation pour ne pas préparer
la dissuasion de demain donc vous
expliqueriez au fond à nos compétiteurs
que notre dissuasion n'est plus
modernisée et que de par la même elle ne
dissuète plus or justement satisfaite
parce que ça repose sur un effort
continu toute formation politique
confondue depuis 1962 81 compris
monsieur le député
1981-1988 compris il y a une continuité
républicaine sur le soutien la
dissuasion nucléaire et sur sa
modernisation parce que c'est ça
modernisation qui permet son efficacité
donc de cela aussi il faudra évidemment
avoir le débat je sais que vous avez le
débat au sein de la nups puisque les
questions liées à l'OTAN des questions
liées à la dissuasion nucléaire les
questions parfois liées aux exportations
d'armes ne sont pas des questions
consensuelles entre vos groupes ce qui
prouve bien que ces sujets sont
complexes et délicats et qu'il vaut
mieux les appréhender avec beaucoup de
précisions mais ce qui ne médite pas
pour autant un rejet du texte en tout
cas je ne le crois pas par cette menace
en tout cas monsieur le député il y a
une certitude c'est que à votre
différence peut-être moi je considère
qu'il y a urgence à tenir ce débat pour
nos forces armées à qui on demande
beaucoup dans un contexte qui se durcit
c'est un débat qui est scruté ça a été
dit par un certain nombre d'entre vous
scrutés par nos alliés scrutés par nos
compétiteurs et je pense qu'il n'y a pas
urgence à rejeter le texte mais au
contraire
urgence à le débattre à l'enrichir et le
cas échéant à le voter je vous remercie
monsieur le ministre
monsieur le rapporteur
merci madame la Présidente difficile
après tout ce qui a été dit de d'en
rajouter un peu plus mais permettez-moi
quand même monsieur le Président de
revenir sur quelques contradictions dans
dans vos propos à la fois vous voulez un
débat large on le propose il est c'est
maintenant c'est aujourd'hui le débat et
on en a pour une ou deux semaines et
avec plaisir et en même temps vous
rejeter le débat par votre initiative
donc moi je me réjouis que vous ouvrez
en fait quelque part le débat à travers
votre démarche avec beaucoup de
contradiction tout de même vous relevez
69 milliards d'euros c'est trop à la fin
de parent c'est trop à la fin de cette
loi de programmation mais en même temps
dans votre discours vous promettez
autant de dépenses donc beaucoup de
contradictions qui va falloir éclairer
et puis si vous voulez mon avis il faut
tout simplement que la France prenne sa
place sa juste place on a une histoire
singulière et c'est important que nous
préservions cette place vous vous
demandiez dans votre discours où est la
place de la France en internationale et
à l'Outre-mer et bien moi je pense que
elle a sa place parce que c'est déjà une
puissance maritime deuxième puissance
maritime en terme de surface et donc
elle doit prendre sa place et qu'elle a
un rôle de puissance d'équilibre et de
nations cadres et donc c'est pour ça que
cette voie de programmation militaire a
été réfléchie d'une certaine façon et
avec un examen approfondi qui a permis
de se dire que il faut que la France de
demain soit en capacité d'avoir son
propre renseignement et vous tenez à ce
qu'on ne soit pas lié à d'autres nations
les États-Unis auxquels contre nation
pour notre enseignement et bien c'est de
l'investissement dans le renseignement
c'est l'investissement dans l'analyse et
dans cette capacité d'action ont eu lieu
et en tout moment et de façon matérielle
et immatérielle alors beaucoup de débats
vont venir je vais ne pas aller plus
loin mais
j'ai hâte en tout cas parce que je suis
persuadé que votre motion de censure de
rejet pardon va être ne va pas être
adopté et donc j'ai hâte de rentrer dans
le débat avec vous et une chose en tout
cas certainement qui nous réunira et
j'en suis sûr c'est tout ce qui concerne
la résistance et l'Ordre de la
Libération et je crois qu'on aura un
beau texte sur ce sujet je vous remercie
je vous remercie
nous passons maintenant aux explications
de vote je rappelle demi par
intervention avec un orateur par groupe
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Paul Lecoq
du groupe GDR
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues l'intervention de Fabien
Roussel nous permet de comprendre que
les députés de la du groupe de la Gauche
démocrate et républicaine sont en
désaccord de fond avec l'architecture
même de notre armée et sur sa doctrine
d'emploi que la présente programmation
militaire amplifie par conséquent même
si certaines dispositions nous
intéressent nous ne pouvons pas voter
cette loi nous doutons fortement que la
montée en puissance de la dissuasion
nucléaire prévue dans cette loi de
programmation militaire et qui
mobilisera plus de 50 milliards d'euros
apportent une plus grande sécurité à nos
concitoyens la guerre en Ukraine ne doit
pas brouiller les pistes cette guerre
est anachronique elle ne va certainement
pas rouvrir un cycle de conflictualité
de ce type le terrorisme l'hybridité des
conflits les tensions dans le monde
cyber et dans l'espace continue de
croître c'est d'ailleurs ce qui est
souligné dans la revue nationale
stratégique contre cela le parapluie
nucléaire n'a aucune utilité pire il
mobilise très largement des crédits qui
auraient pu être
affecté à d'autres tâches comme la
rappeler Fabien Roussel fabriquez plus
de bâtiments de la Marine pour
surveiller les eaux territoriales de nos
territoires d'outre-mer monter plus vite
en compétences dans nos capacités de
surveillance spatiale et cyber
transformer nos armées de manière à
bénéficier d'une rapidité d'intervention
démultipliée face à de potentielles
menaces étatique ou non voilà qui aura
été plus utile selon nous enfin
l'absence totale de débat populaire
autour du rôle de l'armée du budget que
notre nation est prête à y consacrer est
une aberration qui a poussé également
notre groupe à vous proposer de rejeter
pour l'instant la loi de programmation
militaire pour que l'exécutif se remette
au travail et nous présente une version
plus conforme à notre époque au besoin
qui s'y expriment et permettent à nos
concitoyens de s'exprimer sur le sujet
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe najlaine du groupe
libertin indépendant outre-mer et
territoire
merci madame la Présidente il y a en
réalité un minimum trois raisons pour
lesquelles nous serions contre cette
notion de rejet la première et que par
principe le débat doit se faire dans
cette émission et que donc par principe
nous sommes contre l'émotion de rejet la
deuxième est que soit même plutôt
favorable à cette loi de programmation
militaire dans l'attente bien sûr des
débats qui doivent avoir lieu ici et
sous couvert des amendements qui
seraient potentiellement adoptés et la
troisième c'est que pendant deux
semaines nous avons eu de très bons
débats en commission ou il y a eu
l'occasion pour le collègue Roussel
comme pour d'autres d'ailleurs de donner
son point de vue qu'il est dommage que
nous perdions encore une heure de temps
avant de commencer les débats sur cette
proposition de sur ce sur ce rejet sur
ce rejet préalable donc non nous
voterons bien entendu contre elle nous
attendons
les débats avec impatience pour porter
toutes les propositions que notre groupe
a apporté sur cette loi de programmation
militaire je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur François Cormier bouligeon du
groupe Renaissance
monsieur Poutine a provoqué le retour de
la guerre en Europe quand les blés sont
sous la grêle fou qui fait le délicat ne
disait Aragon alors posons-nous les
bonnes questions chers collègues la LPM
inscrit notre défense nationale dans une
logique d'alliance qui par delà les
alternances politiques font depuis le
général de Gaulle notre diplomatie et
notre stratégie militaire que les
communistes les insoumis et leur
rassemblement national s'y opposent
n'est certes pas une surprise mais vous
collègues républicain des autres bancs
seriez-vous prêt à remettre en cause
cette politique solide
la LPM réaffirme et modernise notre
force de dissuasion nucléaire nos
collègues communistes y sont
historiquement opposés et c'est bien
leurs droits mais vous collègues des
autres groupes seriez-vous prêts à
abandonner le bouclier nucléaire qui
assure la paix sur notre sol nationale
depuis 8 décennies c'est-à-dire la
période la plus longue de l'histoire de
France la LPM prévoit de nombreux
investissements pour donner à nos armées
les moyens dont elles ont besoin elle se
traduira par des projets industriels
majeurs qui renforceront notre
souveraineté technologique et créeront
des milliers d'emplois qui parmi nous
seraient prêts à rejeter ces programmes
industriels en regardant droit dans les
yeux nos soldats mais aussi les salariés
de l'ouvrier à l'ingénieur de ces
entreprises françaises de la BITD à
Saint-Nazaire à Bourges et partout
ailleurs en France et nous accepterait
de laisser fuir ses compétences à
l'étranger
mes chers collègues les soldats français
nous regardent les salariés des
entreprises de défense française nous
regardent les citoyens français nous
regardent nous alliés en Europe dans
l'entente et partout dans le monde nous
regarde et les puissances inammitables
nous regardent aussi avec mes collègues
députés du groupe Renaissance nous leur
adressons un message clair nous serons à
la hauteur des enjeux du temps pour
défendre et protéger la France Les
Français et l'Europe nous repousserons
cette motion de rejet idéologique nous
débattrons et voterons ces toits de
programmation militaires
[Applaudissements]
la parole est à Monsieur Laurent
jacobelli du groupe rassemblement
national
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre monsieur
le Président Monsieur le Rapporteur mais
chers collègues les débats commencent
bien entre le groupe communiste qui veut
rejeter ce débat et Monsieur Cormier
bouligeon qui apparemment n'a pas
assisté aux travaux à la Commission et
qui en tirent des conclusions
complètement erronées honnêtement ça
dépend sous les meilleurs auspices
mais nous on va prendre un peu de
hauteur de vue parce qu'on parle de
notre défense et qu'on parle de nos
armées et qu'il reste encore beaucoup à
faire pour retrouver une défense
nationale à la hauteur des nouveaux
enjeux retour de la guerre en Europe
durcissement des plombs des conflits
nouvelle usage des drones luttent
informationsnel qu'il s'agisse de
ressources humaines de capacités ou
encore de notre souveraineté pour être
plus efficace il faut redéfinir les
moyens et la stratégie en matière de
défense dans ce contexte les débats sur
ce projet de loi programmation militaire
seront essentielles ils seront
l'occasion d'évoquer la nécessaire
réparation de nos armées mais aussi
d'imaginer les moyens de préparer nos
forces à défendre la France dans un
contexte de tension croissante
n'oublions pas non plus ces milliers
d'hommes et de femmes prêts à sacrifier
leur vie pour la nation beaucoup restent
à faire pour accompagner leur famille
les héberger décemment et leur verser
une solde digne des efforts qu'il
prodigue chaque jour alors nous privé de
ce débat serait une erreur car de notre
travail pourrait naître un certain
nombre d'évolution et d'amélioration sur
le texte qui nous est proposé à moi bien
sûr mes chers collègues communistes que
vous souhaitiez évitez ce débat pour ne
pas faire éclater au grand jour les
divisions qui traversent la nupesse on
trouve chez vous des pros et des
antinucléaires certains qui rêvent d'une
défense européenne et d'autres qui ne
veulent même pas en entendre parler il
est vrai qu'à la nupaisse pour la
défense comme pour le reste c'est 50
nuances de rouge nos armées méritent
mieux que de la politique politicienne
et cela va pour vous aussi mes chers
collègues c'est la raison pour laquelle
le groupe rassemblement national attaché
à la défense attaché à nos armées
attaché à la souveraineté et attachée au
départ votre a contre cette motion de
rejet préalable merci beaucoup je vous
remercie
la parole est à madame Martin Étienne du
groupe la France insoumise
merci madame la Présidente
collègues ministres le gouvernement a
choisi de rédiger une nouvelle LPM deux
ans avant la fin de l'actuel LPM sans
mener de grandes réflexions publiques
sur nos orientations stratégiques et
avec une étude d'impact une RS et un
rapport clairement insuffisant on nous
parle de 413 millions d'euros pour nos
armées sur 7 ans et d'un budget qui
augmente massivement or dans les faits
cette nouvelle LPM permet au
gouvernement de ne pas appliquer la
précédente en présentant un budget
inférieur à ce qui était initialement
prévu on revote simplement des marches à
3 milliards pour les deux prochaines
années avec une inflation qui va renier
sur ce qui était prévu le gouvernement
crée un effet d'annonce sur de prétendus
augmentation mais les plus fortes
augmentations ont lieu après 2017 de
nombreux programmes sont ainsi reportés
après 2027 pardon le gouvernement nous
promettait une LPM de rupture qui
prennent en compte la guerre en Ukraine
et nous permettent de couvrir ces
nouveaux conflits mais dans les faits de
quelle rupture parlez-vous
vous nous parlez des nouvelles
frontières de l'humanité que sont le
cyber l'espace et les fonds marins mais
nous ça fait 10 ans qu'on vous en parle
il y a rien de nouveau mais alors il y
avait-il urgence à convoquer cette
nouvelle LPM si oui il aurait fallu y
réfléchir en profondeur avec un nouveau
livre blanc sinon nous aurions pu
prendre le temps de travailler une
réelle programmation nous voulons un
débat plus complet qui ne fasse pas
selon le bon vouloir de l'exécutif nous
souhaitons associer pleinement la
représentation nationale et la
population a une large réflexion sur nos
orientations stratégiques nous voterons
donc cette motion de rejet parce que ce
grand moment de planification ne doit
pas être gâché monsieur le ministre vous
l'avez reconnu vous-même dans votre
rapport annexé il y a des erreurs et des
sujets qui mériteraient d'être
retravaillés et je pense
particulièrement ou mesure indemnitaires
que vous avez évoqué dans votre
intervention sans le spécifier dans la
LPM alors donnons-nous le temps
travaillons ces sujets et venons à bout
de l'actuel LPM et redénifie et
redéfinissions nos objectifs avec
sérieux et précision
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
tirio du groupe les républicains
merci Madame le président monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues notre
groupe a évidemment un problème avec
cette motion de rejet préalable du
collègue Roussel je devrais dire du
camarade Russell parce que a-t-il si peu
confiant dans la représentation
nationale et dans la délibération
démocratique pour qu'il refuse que ces
débats sur notre politique de défense et
lieu dans cet enceinte nous sommes ici
au lieu où s'exerce la démocratie alors
n'ayez pas peur du débat ou alors c'est
la vieille tradition moscooter des
bolcheviks qui avaient réduit au silence
les mêmes chevilles majoritaires nous
nous mangeons pas de ce pain là et donc
nous voterons évidemment contre cette
motion de rejet préalable
après sur le fond
quelle folie quelle folie de vouloir
renoncer à la dissuasion nucléaire
aujourd'hui un pays en guerre l'Ukraine
si elle n'avait pas signé le mémorandum
de Budapest aurait cette fonction de
dissuasion et ce ne serait pas des
dizaines de milliers de morts que l'on
connaît et puis vous voulez sortir de
l'OTAN très bien et vous vous plaignez
du montant du budget des dépenses
militaires en évoquant les 413 milliards
par rapport aux autres dépenses mais si
nous sortons de le temps ce n'est pas 2%
qu'il faudra dépenser ces trois à quatre
ou cinq pour cent et lorsque le général
de Gaulle a choisi de sortir du
commandement intégré on était à 3 ou 4%.
alors messieurs un peu de cohérence pour
la sécurité des Français et pour les
armes de la France évidemment cette
motion devrait être rejetée
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Fabien Lainé du
groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres mes
chers collègues et on voit que certains
sont inspirés
les propos de nos collègues communistes
inscrivent à la fois dans une logique
qu'il est à l'heure depuis des décennies
ça nous ramènerait loin peut-être au
Pacte de Varsovie mais il faut le
reconnaître une cohérence elle est la
même et très et parfois très surprenante
personne ne serait étonné de pouvoir
remettre en cause notre modèle d'armée
ou la dissuasion nucléaire là où vous y
voyez une dépense onéreuse qui fait
courir un risque pour la paix nous nous
y voyons un moyen de garantir la
sécurité de notre territoire dans une
logique purement défensive avec une
doctrine française bien établie et
respectée depuis des décennies celle de
la stricte suffisance
nous notre partageons pas non plus vos
positions sur les opérations extérieures
qui se font aussi pour la défense de
notre territoire puisque vous preniez
l'exemple de barkhane les forces
françaises il faut le rappeler sont
intervenus au Mali à la demande des
autorités du pays et je ne pense pas que
ceux qui ont risqué leur vie là-bas vous
direz que cela s'est fait au détriment
de la protection de nos compatriotes
mais bien l'inverse vous opposez aussi
bien des choses et je m'étonne que le
procédé démocratique qui pourrait être
fait à ce texte je vous rappelle débattu
pendant 32 heures dans la seule
commission de la défense sans parler de
la commission des lois sans parler
d'abolition des Affaires étrangères sans
parler de la commission des finances une
revue nationale stratégique a été
publiée pour prendre en compte les
évolutions de la situation mondiale nous
savons depuis des mois qu'une LPM se
prépare nous avons mené des cycles
d'audition pour préparer en commission
nous avons d'ailleurs aussi délocalisé
certaines réunions de la commission en
région pour des battre avec nos
concitoyens où étaient vous
enfin nous allons avoir deux semaines
dans cette émission pour débattre
longuement de points sur lesquels vous
êtes en désaccord avec un rapport indexé
qui a laissé une large liberté d'aborder
tous les sujets ce débat est important
pour nos armées il est important pour
nous concitoyens il est important pour
la sécurité de notre pays je suis
d'ailleurs persuadé que le texte sera
utilement amendé par des propositions
issues ici de nombreux bancs preuve donc
de l'importance d'avoir cette discussion
donc le groupe démocrate s'opposera
évidemment à cette motion de rejet je
vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à madame Isabelle Santiago
du groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la secrétaire d'État
Mesdames et Messieurs les rapporteurs
chers collègues ce projet de loi de
programmation militaire est examinée à
l'heure de la renaissance des empires du
retour de la guerre de haute intensité
en Europe et du réarmement naval
militaire dans le monde dans ce contexte
de retour du tragique cette LPM confirme
la hausse des crédits alloués à nos
armées et s'inscrit dans la continuité
de la précédente loi de programmation
nous avons certains points communs avec
l'analyse du groupe GDR mais nous n'en
avons nous n'en dirons pas toutes les
conclusions entre nos deux parties
l'histoire montrent que la dissuasion
nucléaire et le temps ont toujours été
l'objet d'apprendre des bas
à ce titre nous saluons l'effort réalisé
afin de garantir la crédibilité d'une
dissuasion nucléaire à sa strict
suffisance doctrine instaurée par
François Mitterrand et à laquelle les
socialistes attachés à ce modèle d'armée
nous souhaitons comme le groupe GDR que
la France puisse préserver saoulevée
défendent ses intérêts vitaux notamment
en outre-mer mais le groupe socialiste
passe un respect de nos engagements avec
l'OTAN les partenaires au sein de
l'Alliance atlantique nous prenons à
plus long terme une autonomie
stratégique européenne de la défense au
sein de l'Alliance atlantique qui reste
évidemment à construire ainsi toutes ces
raisons pour toutes ces raisons nous ne
pourrons voter la motion de rejet
préalable la LPM est certes critiquable
avec ses forces et ses faiblesses mais
c'est justement l'objet du débat que
nous souhaitons
évidemment
indispensable on est écouté nos armées
le mérite nos partenaires les Français
nous regardent et nos compétiteurs aussi
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Loïc Herbrand
du groupe horizon merci madame la
Présidente dans le groupe horizon nous
aimons la clarté nous avons je dois dire
été un peu dérouté par la demande de la
nupes qui nous dit finalement que je
cite la défense nationale ne se négocie
pas mais apparemment ces budgets se
rejettent avant même d'être étudié
l'orateur nous dit aussi vouloir un
débat national mais en même temps veut
empêcher celui devant la représentation
nationale alors nous le groupe horizon
oui oui nous voulons mieux rémunérer
ceux qui risquent leur vie pour la
France oui nous voulons protéger nos
concitoyens et faire les choix
stratégiques qui vont protéger nos
enfants et nos petits-enfants oui nous
voulons mieux armer et mieux protéger
ceux qui nous défendent au quotidien
pour toutes ces raisons relativement
simple nous voterons contre cette motion
de rejet
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Julien Bayou du
groupe écologiste merci madame la
Présidente chers collègues on va pas
voter cette
motion une question de méthode ça a été
dit il y a des débats importants dont
l'assemblée doit se saisir sur les
retraites par exemple j'espère que nous
aurons le débat et je prends au mot
Renaissance qui refuse cette motion de
rejet nous aurons le débat le 8 juin je
crois et sur la défense c'est maintenant
et en particulier sur la défense
l'assemblée doit se saisir du régalien
nous les écologistes nous réfutons
l'idée qu'il y a un domaine réservé aux
seuls présidents de la République et je
n'achète pas du tout l'argument que la
présidentielle aurait soldé la question
de la dissuasion nucléaire il
n'appartient pas à un seul homme de
décider de la menace d'une destruction
massive d'une partie de l'humanité et
donc soit cette dissuasion est partagée
par l'ensemble de la population soit
elle doit être abandonnée la même
manière sur le porte-avion ça engage des
coups absolument colossaux qui nous
empêche de mener à bien toutes les
autres missions et donc
vous comprenez Cyrielle châtelain notre
président te développera notre vision de
la loi de programmation militaire mais
nous souhaitons que ces débats soient
approfondis plutôt que interrompu et
puis troisième point et je dois le
saluer je profite des quelques secondes
qui me restent on a eu un débat
intéressant en commission je le remercie
le président de la commission et je
remercie le ministre pour sa patience on
travaille les réponses vous me direz que
c'est la base et en vrai on devrait pas
le relever mais c'est tellement rare
c'est tellement rare vis-à-vis de ce
gouvernement
que je me dois de le saluer je regrette
vraiment que le gouvernement se saisisse
pas de cette configuration inattendue
qui permettrait une co-construction
c'est entièrement de la faute du
gouvernement si nous n'y parvenons pas
mais puisque nous y sommes parvenus à
peu près en commission et bien nous
souhaitons que ces débats prospère en
hémicycle je vous remercie je vous
remercie nous allons donc maintenant
procéder au scrutin je vais donc mettre
en voix la motion de rejet préalable je
vous prie de bien vouloir reg agner aux
places
le scrutin est ouvert
le scrutin est clos
voici le résultat du scrutin votant 185
exprimé 185 majorité 93 pour 27 contre
158 la motion de rejet préalable n'est
pas adoptée
nous passons donc à la discussion
générale
la parole est à Monsieur thématé le
Gailly du groupe Gauche démocrate et
républicaine
[Applaudissements]
monsieur les présidents commission
mesdames Messieurs les rapporteurs
dans l'une de nos langues les hautes
militaire se traduit par
ait
pas faire la paix
ainsi
on voit les militaires comme des hommes
de paix comme des pacificateurs et pas
des hommes de guerre
si il me semble le sens de l'histoire
chaque État nation depuis la fin des
deux grandes guerres sarment pour se
protéger protéger sa souveraineté et
celle de ses alliés
pour autant
le choix opéré dans cette loi de
programmation militaire
d'investir massivement pour le
renouvellement de la force de dissuasion
nucléaire interroge compte à cet
objectif de paix
c'est un choix qui vient heurter toutes
les victimes des essais nucléaires
français
à l'heure où l'État reconnaît
difficilement encore aujourd'hui les
conséquences humaines et
environnementales des 210 essais
nucléaires menées en Algérie et en
Polynésie
qu'en est-il d'une réelle indemnisation
des victimes et de leur famille qu'en
est-il de la dette de l'État français
vis-à-vis de la protection sociale
généralisée pour les nésienne ou encore
qu'en est-il de l'Institut du concert
qui a été promis lors de la visite du
président Emmanuel Macron pour
l'Indonésie qui devait être financé
conjointement entre la Polynésie et la
France
j'ai entendu depuis le début de notre
rencontre d'aujourd'hui
la grandeur de la France qui s'est
érigée grâce à cette dissuasion
nucléaire pour nous cette grandeur s'est
dirigée dans le mensonge et dans le déni
des milliers de Polynésiens victimes de
maladies radio réduites je voudrais un
exemple
l'île la plus proche de mouru
193 et ses nucléaires c'est 300 km
d'écart si entre Paris et
Clermont-Ferrand et Limoges est-ce que
vous aurez accepté de faire tirer 193 et
ses nucléaires à Limoges
pour le prix de la grandeur de la France
je ne pense pas
de plus les conditions de travail de vie
des militaires aurait dû être le cœur de
notre réflexion j'ai une pensée
particulière pour les militaires venant
des territoires d'outre-mer qui sont
nombreux à rejoindre les rangs de
l'armée française mais qui font face à
des difficultés particulières
éloignement géographique et familiale
changement culturel discrimination frein
dans le révolution de carrière puisque
peu d'entre eux accèdent à des postes de
commandement en bonne intelligence c'est
par respect pour nos militaires anciens
combattants et victimes civiles il
aurait été plus judicieux d'augmenter
massivement le budget alloué à
l'amélioration des conditions de vie des
militaires et à leur reconversion
professionnelle notamment le retour des
jeunes d'outre-mer dans leur pays
respectifs à qui on empêche le retour en
soi-disant un retour en vacances alors
que c'est dans leur propre pays
en tant que député
polynésien je ne peux pas parler dans
cette loi de programmation militaire de
l'accent de Pacifique
c'est LPM vient confirmer l'intérêt de
la France
en Océanie et dans l'océan Indien de
cette volonté de faire barrage peut-être
à certains états concurrents
un autre regard
c'est une stratégie qui est imposée
immilatéralement et parfois peut entrer
en contradiction avec nos propres
intérêts et partenariats avec nos
voisins en Océanie la Polynésie souhaite
construire son propre soft power le
Pacifique Wei doit être notre repère
afin de fédérer l'ensemble des États
océaniens pour leurs intérêts et non
ceux des grandes puissances la France
comme l'ensemble des pays occidentaux
peuvent être nos alliés encore faut-il
que nous soyons à la table des
négociations et discuter d'égale à égale
d'État souverain État souverain
et se respecter mutuellement
c'est le vœu que nous formulons pour ces
10 prochaines années ce qui ne sont pour
le pas être l'esprit de cette loi de
programmation militaire mais peut-être à
l'issue célibataire
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Christophe nagelaine du groupe
liberté indépendant outre-mer et
territoire
madame la Présidente Mesdames monsieur
le ministre la messieu les rapporteurs
chers collègues l'engagement de nos
forces armées au quotidien partout dans
le monde nous oblige à assurer à nos
militaire des moyens à la hauteur de
leur engagement et du sacrifice de même
mais aussi de leur famille on veut la
situation actuelle en Ukraine et contenu
du risque du retour des conflits à haute
intensité nous constatons une course à
l'armement dans laquelle une grande
partie de nos voisins européens et de
nos alliés sont déjà entrés les budgets
de défense se sont renforcés la
constitution de stocks stratégique c'est
accéléré plus qu'une compétition entre
voisins nous le faisons face à un espace
international grevé par la concurrence
économique et traversée par des
rivalités géopolitiques
l'effort budgétaire de défense
concernant cet LPM il faut le
reconnaître et au rendez-vous 4
milliards sur 7 ans c'est une somme plus
que substantielle cependant il faut
aussi il est important relativiser
certains effets d'annonces et nous avons
eu l'occasion de le dire en commission
je pense notamment à l'inflation et à
l'exécution annuelle de cette
trajectoire qui sera il faut le
reconnaître un défi comme nous avons eu
l'occasion de le dire à plusieurs
reprises tout comme d'ailleurs le
Conseil d'État et le Conseil des
finances publiques les marches annuelles
les plus hautes auront lieu en fin de
quinquennat néanmoins nous estimons et
nous pensons que peu importe celui ou
celle qui gagnera à l'élection en 2027
ne voyons pas comment il ou elle
pourrait revenir sur cet investissement
en faveur de nos militaires mais il est
dommages de ne pas avoir investi dès
maintenant et d'attendre cette échéance
de plus nous alertons à nouveau sur le
manque de données liées au 13,3
milliards d'euros de ressources extra
budgétaires une somme là aussi loin
d'être négligeable nous portons des
amendements afin d'obtenir des
explications détaillées et d'assurer une
meilleure trajectoire des premiers
amendements et des ont été déjà répondu
en commission mais nous continuerons
d'emporter un certain nombre
en regret aussi les crédits massifs qui
ont déjà été actés sans débat et qui
seront donc implicitement validé avec le
simple vote du rapport annexé la mise en
oeuvre de cette LPM doit pour nous être
l'occasion pour le Parlement de se
réapproprier la défense nationale nous
regrettons l'insuffisance de la clause
de revoyure en l'état cela conduirait
qu'en moins 2021 un simple débat
nous avons proposé des mesures pour
conforter là encore les pouvoirs
d'évaluation du Parlement nous saluons
donc les rectifications apportées en
commission pour renforcer le pouvoir de
contrôle des commissaires de la Défense
nationale sur l'exécution de la LPM et
qui ont été soutenus par l'ensemble des
groupes
autre sujet primordial l'engagement de
nos armées dans les territoires
ultramarins il est nécessaire d'aboutir
à une véritable continuité territoriale
de notre défense ces moyens sont
nécessaires pour protéger les citoyens
ultramarins et surveiller notre Z2 nous
invitons le gouvernement à penser un
angle ultra marin dans la LPM il y a eu
la semaine dernière je crois d'ailleurs
un rendez-vous entre monsieur le
ministre et les différents députés
ultramarins mais cela doit pas être
suffisant nous devons impérativement
avoir un chapitre globalisé dans la LPM
sur les outre-mer nous saluons néanmoins
le choix de consacrer 13 milliards
d'euros sur la période à la souveraineté
en outre-mer nous avons également alerté
sur la situation particulière dans
l'océan Indien qui appelle à une
consolidation des moyens des forces
armées dans la zone sud qui garantissent
la protection du territoire et assure la
coopération depuis la Réunion et Mayotte
nous avons des demandes concrètes et
notamment l'affectation d'un
patrouilleur outre-mer à temps plein
pour Mayotte pour protéger nos
frontières enfin je tiens à rappeler que
les ambitions de la LPM ne pourront être
menées qu'à la condition d'offrir un
cadre optimal à nos armées le plan
famille 2 doté de 750 millions d'euros
sur la période transparaît dans le
rapport annexé et nous attendrons au
bien entendu des détails sur l'enveloppe
sur le reste de l'enveloppe des
précisions ont été apportées en
commission mais il semble nécessaire
d'aller plus loin donc notre groupe
reconnaît les efforts menés par le
ministère appellent surtout à mieux
associer les collectivités locales afin
de prendre de répondre plus efficacement
aux besoins concrets des familles nous
saluons les débats et les travaux qui
ont eu lieu en commission et en amont
l'investissement et le travail du
ministre sur le sujet ça a été rappelé
par un certain nombre de collègues ça
n'a pas toujours été le cas dans ce
qu'on a pu voir depuis le début de cette
mandature donc merci monsieur le
ministre et en responsabilité notre
groupe
votera en faveur de ce texte sous
réserve du sort des amendements que nous
portons je vous remercie je vous
remercie
la parole est à Madame Anne gente du
groupe Renaissance
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les ministres monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues alors
autant de pays brisent toute liberté
individuelle et tente d'exporter hors de
leur frontière leur modèle mortifère je
veux d'abord saluer nos soldats tombés
ou blessés pour notre drapeau drapeau
que nos armées défendent avec tant
d'engagement et de courage pour nous
permettre de nous tenir aujourd'hui
debout dans cette hémicycle libre et
fier de défendre notre devise Liberté
Égalité Fraternité
chers collègues nous sommes ici pour
parler d'avenir de l'avenir de nos
armées de celui des hommes et des femmes
qui la composent et de celui de leur
famille qui s'engagent à leurs côtés de
l'avenir de notre défense de celui de
notre nation et donc de notre avenir à
toutes et tous car cette loi de
programmation militaire porte une vision
de la France de sa place dans le monde
et répond à la question quel modèle
d'armée pour demain petit retour en
arrière d'abord 3 décennies de
sous-investissement avait conduit nos
armées au bord de l'effondrement par la
précédent LPM notre majorité avait
renversé cette tendance en engageant une
politique de rupture qui mettait enfin
un terme à l'érosion de nos forces
armées cette ambition s'est traduite
très concrètement par une augmentation
du budget de la mission d'échange puis
par une exécution budgétaire que dis-je
une surexécution budgétaire uneaniement
saluée autant de gages de confiance et
de crédibilité pour cette nouvelle loi
de programmation nouvelle car le de la
guerre à haute intensité à nos portes en
Ukraine sur le sol européen la guerre
hybride mondialisée l'accentuation des
tensions internationales ou encore les
multiples défis globaux justifient que
nous répondions sans attendre à ces
bouleversements de notre environnement
stratégique en somme il s'agit désormais
d'engager un effort de transformation
permettant à la France de conserver une
supériorité opérationnelle d'ajouter
donc de la profondeur à ce qui est la
signature de nos armées manoeuvre
vitesse audace adaptabilité et haute
précision
le ministre et les rapporteur l'ont
appelé avant moi nos fondamentaux seront
donc consolidés qu'il s'agisse par
exemple de la protection de nos
territoires y compris le tramarins de la
crédibilité de la permanence de notre
dissuasion nucléaire clé de voûte de
notre défense assurance vie de notre
pays ou de l'amélioration des conditions
de vie et de travail des militaires et
civils de la défense nous y ajouterons
des moyens inédits alloués au
renseignements et à l'innovation pour
enferser notre liberté d'accès d'action
dans les espaces communs et les nouveaux
champs de conflictualité que sont
l'espace le cyber les drones ou encore
la défense solaire enfin l'économie de
guerre impose de renforcer notre
autonomie stratégique avec la
sécurisation des approvisionnements
critiques la constitution de stock
stratégique ou encore la relocalisation
de filières de production sur le
territoire national ou européen
l'excellente qualité des débats que je
veux souligner en commission a permis
d'enrichir la copie présentée par notre
ministre comme sur la rémunération des
militaires sur la diversité la
représentativité notamment des femmes et
de nos concitoyens ultramarins sur les
parcours international de nos soldats
sur le renforcement des réserves qui
seront accessibles aussi aux Français
établir de France sur l'influence
consacrée comme fonction stratégique sur
le rôle accru du Parlement et enfin sur
la prise en compte du changement
climatique dans le fonctionnement de nos
armées je salue donc le rejet par
l'Assemblée nationale de la motion qui
nous a été présentée par le groupe GDR
permettant ainsi au débat de se
poursuivre nous le devons à nos armées
qui nous regardent nous le devons à
notre pays
mes chers collègues cette trajectoire
exige un effort conséquent que la nation
est prête à engager un effort qui prend
en compte deux exigences fortes celle de
porter notre défense à la hauteur de nos
ambitions et celle de respecter les
contraintes budgétaires nationales que
nous connaissons le président de la
République a donc arbitré pour un budget
de 413 milliards d'euros soit une
augmentation de 40% par rapport à la
précédente notre programmation et c'est
un budget qui sera donc plus que doublé
entre 2017 et 2030 mes chers collègues
nos armées ainsi transformés non
assurons que mieux notre sécurité n'en
défendrons que mieux notre liberté non
préserverons que mieux notre
souveraineté n'en serviront que mieux
nos engagements d'allier exemplaires
fiables et de haut niveau prête à verser
le prix du sang au sein de l'OTAN au
service de l'autonomie stratégique
européenne et je veux partager avec vous
les trois mots les trois mots que nos
alliés utilisent pour qualifier nos
armées
savoir faire crédibilité et volonté
cette loi de programmation militaire
entend les conserver soyons en fier je
vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Marine Le Pen
pour le groupe rassemblement national
madame la Présidente
monsieur le ministre à mes chers
collègues
depuis les années 60 la loi de
programmation militaire permet à la
France de disposer d'une vision
stratégique de moyens long terme et de
déterminer les moyens matériels et
humains que souhaite consacrer notre
pays à la défense de ces citoyens de son
territoire et de ses intérêts elle
permet aussi à notre base industrielle
et technologique de défense de disposer
d'une visibilité
indispensable à la préservation de
centaines de milliers d'emplois
essentiels à l'exercice de la
souveraineté nationale nous savons tous
notre outil militaire doit répondre à
deux enjeux majeurs pour notre nation en
premier lieu la défense de notre
territoire qu'il soit métropolitain
ultramarins sous-marin ou spatial
en cela l'ambition de ce texte reste sur
certains segments trop faibles mais je
comprends étant donné le bilan
catastrophique de la macronie en termes
de finances publiques qu'il peut être
difficile de faire plus le second est de
défendre la place de notre pays dans le
concert des nations cette place si
singulière qui fait de notre pays une
nation à part regarder par toutes les
grandes puissances j'ai durant la
dernière campagne longuement développée
ma vision de cette France puissance en
ce début de discussion je me satisfais
que l'outil militaire que vous
programmez pour les prochaines années ne
soit pas incompatible avec la politique
étrangère et de défense que je souhaite
mener l'actualisation prévue dans ce
texte permettra d'ajuster notre outil
militaire quand nous arriverons au
pouvoir
le contexte géopolitique
économique dégradée nous oblige à faire
de cette LPM 2024-2030 un texte
irréprochable sur le plan de la
sincérité budgétaire comme sur celui des
capacités militaires monsieur le
ministre vous avez réaffirmé le rôle
majeur de la dissuasion nucléaire et en
cela nous vous soutiendrons sans réserve
nul ne serait remettre en cause l'un des
piliers de notre défense
héritage du gaullisme car l'existence de
la France en tant que pays libre n'est
pas un acquis mortel et doit toujours
être défendu sur le plan conventionnel
en revanche nous inquiétudes demeurent
certes les efforts entrepris depuis 2015
sont louables et ont permis de mettre un
terme à la saigner infligé aux armées
dans le cadre des dividendes de la paix
des années 90 mais ils ne sont toujours
pas assez rapides et surtout pas assez
massif budgétairement
face à l'instabilité croissante du monde
il est plus que temps de comprendre
qu'une armée de peut-être réellement
complète si elle demeure comme la nôtre
échantillonnaire d'abord nos amis
doivent être capables de conduire tous
les types d'opérations de manière
autonome or à titre d'exemple nous ne
disposons pas d'hélicoptère de transport
lourd au Mali il a fallu l'assistance de
la Royal Air Force votre projet de LPM
ne répond pas à cette question ensuite
nos capacités ne doivent pas être
soumises aux aléas des chimérique
coopérations européennes que sont le
scalf le scalf et le MG CS face à
l'attitude inacceptable de nos
partenaires allemands plus prendre que
vous à défendre leurs intérêts nationaux
il nous paraît en effet indispensable de
mettre en place des alternatives
souveraines
puisque nous parlons Europe de la
défense concept en lequel vous êtes bien
les seuls à croire prenons un autre
exemple la facilité européenne pour la
paix certes la contribution du ministère
des armées sera demain exclue de la
trajectoire des besoins financiers mais
trouvez-vous normal monsieur le ministre
que le contribuable français des bourses
de centaines de millions d'euros pour
permettre par exemple au gouvernement
polonais d'acheter des matériels
américains et sud-coréens
ne pensez-vous pas que cette manne
financière pourrait permettre de vrai à
la transformation de nos armées dont
vous faites je l'ai bien compris si
grand cas sur ce sujet aussi vos
professions de foi
latéralistes pardon ça de Monsieur le
Ministre non comme les témoignages d'une
vision stratégique mais comme des dogmes
que je considère terriblement daté
permettez-moi enfin d'invoquer les
femmes et les hommes qui constituent le
fer de lance de nos armées et de leurs
témoigner mon a défectible soutien ils
incarnent la discipline l'honneur et le
courage autant de vertus sociales que
nous chérissons et souhaitons voir
prospérer mais j'avoue également avoir
du mal à comprendre la politique que
vous menez en la matière alors même que
nos armées font face à une hémorragie de
départ un phénomène c'est vrai qui
concerne l'ensemble de la fonction
publique
en conclusion notre groupe aborde ses
débats dans un esprit constructif et
apaisé nous le devons à nos soldats qui
ont choisissant le métier des âmes
accepte de mourir pour que d'autres
vivent
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Bastien Lachaud
du groupe la France insoumise
[Applaudissements]
comment porter au plus haut pour la
France et pour le monde un certain dont
elle est enveloppée les chances de la
paix et si malgré son effort et sa
volonté de paix elle est attaquée
comment porter au plus haut les chances
de salut les moyens de la victoire ainsi
s'exprimer Jean Jaurès il y a plus de
100 ans depuis cette même tribune les
termes du débat actuel n'ont pas varié
plus que de 413 milliards c'est de notre
vision pour la France c'est de notre
ambition pour la place de la France dans
le monde dont nous débattons comment
voulons-nous œuvrer pour la paix et
défendre la France le monde incertain
que décrivait Jaurès n'est encore plus
aujourd'hui crise financière monétaire
retour des logiques de blocs retour de
la guerre en Europe avec la terrible
agression de l'Ukraine par la Russie et
crise climatique qui surdétermine tout
l'humanité tout entière est en péril
alors deux options ça fera nous accepter
la logique de bloc se résigner à la
guerre ou bien œuvré pour la paix et
l'intérêt général humain la France fit
de la grande révolution du 1789 et de la
Déclaration universelle des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen forte de sa
république universaliste doit se faire
le porte-parole de l'intérêt général
humain qui d'autre le pourrait la France
est une grande puissance elle n'est pas
une nation occidentale elle est présente
sur l'ensemble des océans sa plus grande
frontière terrestre est avec le Brésil
sa plus grande frontière maritime est
avec l'Australie notre territoire subira
de plein fouet les effets du
bouleversement climatique face à de tels
risques la France doit œuvrer au sein de
l'ONU qu'il faudra revivifier pour la
création d'une force de réponse aux
catastrophes climatiques rendre toute sa
place à l'ONU céréaffirmer le primauté
du multilatéralisme et du droit
international c'est offrir une
alternative au retour de la logique des
blocs qu'ils soient États-Unis ou
chinois pour être crédible dans ses
choix la France doit retrouver la voie
singulière qu'elle portait dans le
concert des nations lorsque le général
de Gaulle l'avait fait quitter le
commandement intégré de l'OTAN en 1977
or depuis 2008 la France a réintégré ce
commandement pour quel bilan pour quel
bénéfice la foi de la France
porte-t-elle plus loin ou au contraire
est-elle rendue inaudible par son
alignement sur des intérêts qui ne sont
ni les siens ni ceux de l'intérêt
général humain il en va de même pour le
mythe de l'Europe de la défense alors
que le président Macron entendait
façonner une autonomie stratégique
européenne les traiter la firme rien
n'est possible hors de l'Alliance
atlantique
c'est indépendance retrouvée nous
permettrait de proposer à toutes les
nations qui le souhaitent notamment
européennes de nouvelles coopérations
nous devons relancer des discussions
pour un nouveau traité faisant de
l'espace un bien commun de l'humanité
nous devons œuvrer pour la mise en place
d'un droit international du cyber nous
devons œuvrer dans le respect du Traité
de Non proliférations au désarmement
nucléaires multilatéral des puissances
dotées et détentrices
cette ambition n'est pas contradictoire
avec le fait de réaffirmer
qu'aujourd'hui la dissuasion de
nucléaire demeure la clé de voûte de
notre défense nationale mais si la
dissuasion reste crédible aujourd'hui
quand sera-t-il demain qui peut nous
garantir que la dissuasion nucléaire ne
sera pas un jour notre nouvelle ligne
Maginot quel dirigeant responsable
pourrait affirmer aujourd'hui que dans
30 40 60 ans la dissuasion nucléaire
sera infaillible car avec les ruptures
technologiques dans l'espace dans les
fonds marins dans le cyber dans le
domaine de l'hyper vélocité il se
pourrait que notre dissuasion soit
contournée ce risque même un film il
n'est pas acceptable de s'y exposer et
d'y exposer la nation dès lors nous
devons l'anticiper il faut explorer
toutes les pistes d'action dissuasives
crédibles y compris non nucléaires c'est
pourquoi nous proposons de créer un
commissariat à la dissuasion de demain
elle sera peut-être spatiale cyber ou
autre
il est certain en tout cas que l'avenir
de notre nation se jouera dans ces
espaces nos entreprises de défense Excel
dans ces domaines comme dans les autres
grâce aux ouvriers spécialisés haute
techniciens et aux ingénieurs qui font
leur puissance nous devons les ramener
dans le giron public pour rester maître
de notre destin nous devons mobiliser
toutes les compétences c'est pourquoi
nous proposons une conception citoyenne
loin de votre SNU gadget réactionnaires
et folkloriques qui n'apportent rien à
la défense de notre pays mais fait peser
une dépend une menace de plusieurs
milliards d'euros sur votre
programmation notre construction
citoyenne sera le moyen de mettre la
totalité de la nation en mouvement pour
œuvrer contre les effets du changement
climatique et les crises multiples qui
l'engendrera l'avenir de notre nation
dépend enfin des femmes et des hommes
qui s'engagent pour la défense de notre
patrie nous devons leur garantir des
conditions d'exercices et une
rémunération et un accompagnement
exemplaire pour nous blesser nos anciens
combattants les enjeux présents et
futurs sont immenses notre devoir est
d'y répondre en donnant aux armes de la
France les moyens nécessaires pour la
défense de la patrie
à toute phase utile je vous signale
également que lorsque vous exprimez les
usage saluer le gouvernement la
commission vos collègues et moi-même la
parole est à Monsieur Jean-Louis
Thériault pour le groupe les
républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames les
ministres monsieur le ministre mes chers
collègues une LPM n'est pas une loi
comme les autres c'est le cœur du
régalien et d'une certaine manière elle
est sacrée au sens où l'entendait Régis
Debré ce qui légitime le sacrifice et
interdit le sacrilège le sacrifice c'est
celui de celle et de ceux qui portent
l'uniforme de la France le sacrilège ce
serait de jauger cette loi pas comme les
autres à l'aune de médiocre
considération politicienne
venons-en au fond cette LPM représente
un effort majeur de 413 milliards
d'euros mais demeurons lucides la guerre
est à nos portes en Europe les menaces
terroristes sont toujours là nous
atteindrons 2% du PIB c’était 3% durant
la guerre froide ne nous payons pas de
mots ce n'est pas une loi historique
c'est une loi raisonnable pouvons-nous
nous en satisfaire l'essentiel est sauf
la dissuasion nucléaire clé de voûte de
nos intérêts vitaux qui permettent de
calibrer tout le reste et bien assuré
les grands programmes sont préservés la
préparation de l'avenir et la
compétitivité de notre BITD nécessaire à
une future remontée en puissance sont
prises en compte même si il est
certainement possible d'aller plus loin
pour notre souveraineté industrielle
face au dilemme mascohérence vous avez
privilégié la cohérence et c'est
bienvenus il ne sert à rien d'avoir des
matériels dans les hangars sans pouvoir
produire les effets pour lesquels ils
ont été conçus mais nos forces
conventionnelles
demeureront partiellement
échantillonnaire dans notre mission sur
la haute intensité nous avions chiffré
les manques à 40 milliards ce trou n'est
pas comblé car nous avons à faire face
aux nouveaux champs de conflictualité
spatiale cyber grand fond que nous
n'avions étudié qu'à la marge cette loi
y répond est plutôt bien cependant je ne
renie rien de ce que j'avais écrit la
masse n'est pas totalement au
rendez-vous
mais la défense est globale il n'est pas
de défense forte sans économie saine il
n'est pas d'économie forte sans financer
pour reprendre les mots du général de
Gaulle la politique et l'économie sont
liées l'une à l'autre comme le son
l'action et la vie et nous savons tous
hélas l'ampleur de nos déficits la dette
c'est la faiblesse le risque du chantage
de nos créanciers au pire le scénario
grec alors il faudra bien faire avec
cette enveloppe derrière les chiffres
cette LPM traduit implicitement une
vision elle préserve notre statue de
puissance mondiale mais renonce à
renforcer le corps aérothérèse c'est un
pari un choix le pari c'est qu'en Europe
l'attrition subie par la Russie
sera-t-elle que dans la décennie à venir
nous ne serons pas engagés au sol ou
dans les airs le choix c'est qu'en
agissant ainsi nous renonçons à
renforcer notre influence dans le auprès
de nos alliés d'Europe centrale c'est
dommage car le temps a vu humaine est
l'horizon de la sécurité de notre
continent nos alliés n'acceptent
l'autonomie stratégique que du Blue des
lèvres nous ne sommes dupes de rien les
Américains sont nos alliés et nos
concurrents mais aux heures décisives il
faut choisir dans l'affaire de Cuba ou
de Berlin le général de Gaulle l'avait
fait notre choix est clair entre une
grande démocratie et l'autocratie nous
choisirons toujours le camp de la
liberté
budgétairement cette LPM pose deux
questions celle des Rex et celle des
marches monsieur le ministre vous avez
accepté de sécuriser les Rex en
commission en donnant un avis favorable
un amendement de notre groupe que j'ai
eu l'honneur de portée merci de cette
approche éminemment constructive qui
nous a rassuré il reste les marches 3
milliards en début de LPM 4,7 après
cette mandature même si je suis bien
conscient quels sont cumulatives une
partie des décalages sont
compréhensibles nous devons privilégier
les solutions souveraines même plus
tardives d'autres sont contestables si
nous vous proposons de les améliorer ce
sera à la marge pense suggérant des
ajouts capacitaires de hasard ce n'est
pas le rôle du Parlement de dire s'il
faut 50 Jaguar de plus ou sans griffon
de moins nous ne insisterons à la marge
sur le niveau de préparation des troupes
car elles améliorent la cohérence
garantit une armée plus affûtée avec
plus d'Allons au combat fort de ces
constats nous abordons ces débats avec
bienveillance mais aussi avec vigilance
pour la sécurité des Français et le bien
des armes de la France en oubliant pas
que ce que nous allons voter ce sont des
hommes qui demain seront au contact au
combat et feront peut-être le sacrifice
de leur vie à nous de leur donner les
moyens je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame josipuito du
groupe démocrate
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre mesdames les secrétaires d'État
chers amis monsieur le Président de la
Commission de la Défense monsieur le
rapporteur chers collègues je me réjouis
avec l'ensemble des députés démocrates
que nous ouvrions aujourd'hui près de 15
jours de débats consacrés à la défense à
nos armées et à travers elle à celles et
ceux qui chaque jour portent haut et
fort les couleurs de notre pays pour
assurer notre protection je voudrais
également avoir une pensée pour les
Ukrainiens qui se battent toujours pour
leur pays pour leur liberté et pour
défendre les valeurs qui nous sont
chères comme l'ont récemment rien
démontré d'ailleurs les annonces du
président de la République la France est
à leur côté et les soutiendra tant que
nécessaire
l'examen en commission est venu rappeler
utilement que le budget des armées ne
sera pas imputé par l'aide que nous
continuerons d'apporter aux Ukrainiens
ainsi malgré l'importance de ce soutien
l'ambition de moderniser nos armées que
nous portons à vos côtés monsieur le
ministre reste intacte avec ce budget de
413 milliards d'euros et chers collègues
il nous faut penser pour une fois autant
long nous sommes tous conscients que cet
argent représente un effort important
pour la nation nous sommes aussi
conscients que cette somme a pu attirer
de nombreuses convoitises quant à son
utilisation aussi personne ne s'étonne
de voir ce qui aspire à gouverner dans
quelques années proposait d'avancer dès
aujourd'hui l'ensemble des
investissements sans se soucier du poids
pour notre dépense publique mais surtout
sans se soucier de l'adaptation à notre
modèle de l'armée
l'imparable démonstration de leurs
illusions a été faite par le Ministre en
commission avec un mot d'ordre qui sera
celui de mon groupe pour les jours à
venir sur ce texte la cohérence car
c'est en toute cohérence qu'il a d'abord
été demandé aux armées leurs besoins
pour construire au mieux un budget
ambitieux qui se rapportait après de 69
milliards d'euros par an d'ici 2030 au
plus haut depuis 3 décennies c'est en
cohérence avec notre stratégie à long
terme portée depuis 60 ans que nous
continuons d'investir dans notre
dissuasion garante de notre indépendance
et de la place de la France dans le
monde
c'est encore incohérence avec le modèle
d'armée que nous souhaitons léguer que
nous actionons les investissements vers
les enjeux essentiels des conflits de
haute intensité à venir le spatial le
cyber les drones mais aussi plus
simplement des municiens les munitions
pardon et le maintien en conditions
opérationnelles c'est enfin en cohérence
avec l'objectif de demeurer un
partenaire fidèle que nous garantissons
la place de la France comme nation cadre
de l'OTAN tout en renforçant l'autonomie
stratégique européenne au travers de
partenariats solides et mutuellement
bénéfiques tels que le SCAF le mgcs et
de nombreux autres coopérations
européennes je formule aussi le vœu au
nom des députés démocrates que ces
coopérations européennes continuent à se
développer tant elle renforce
l'indépendance de notre continent et à
travers lui celui de la France je le
sais au débat reviendront sur l'enjeu de
ces alliances ceux qui pensent renforcer
la France tout en la sortant des
partenari qui font sa force et
maintiennent de son influence se
retrouveront face à l'évidence de leur
contradiction on ne peut espérer
demeurer une puissance de premier rang
sans pouvoir compter sur le fidèles
alliés au-delà de ces questions
matérielles et stratégiques que cette
LPM porte une ambition nouvelle pour
renforcer le lien armé nation élément
central auquel mon groupe portera une
attention particulière nous devons
collectivement encourager nos
concitoyens à retrouver le sens de
l'engagement pour leur pays quel que
soit que ce soit au niveau de nos
réserves ou pour les plus jeunes avec le
SNU madame la secrétaire d'État la
compréhension des enjeux de notre
sécurité mais surtout des valeurs qui
nous unissent c'est une étape
essentielle pour bâtir une nation forte
et résiliente face aux crises
il y a en fait la reconnaissance la
reconnaissance de celles et ceux qui
consacrent leur vie à protéger notre
pays leur engagement doit évidemment
continuer à être valorisé et nous y
serons très vigilants dans l'application
de cette loi mais aussi la
reconnaissance de celles et ceux qui
partagent la vie de ces militaires ils
vivent eux aussi au rythme de l'armée
parfois au détriment de la au détriment
du leur nous continuerons de travailler
pour faire reconnaître ce qui doit être
vu comme leur engagement pour la nation
je tiens d'ailleurs à saluer le plan
blessé présenté récemment par Patricia
mirales qui prend en compte toutes les
situations et leur implication au
quotidien pour ses blessés mais aussi
pour leur famille ainsi notre assemblée
devra rester attentive aux avancées
promues dans le texte et nous nous
réjouissons des pouvoirs de contrôle
dans le Parlement disposera pour
effectuer ce travail aussi si nous
souhaitons apporter encore quelques
améliorations à ce texte au travers de
nos différents amendements le groupe
démocrate soutiendra bien évidemment
cette LPM historique je vous remercie je
vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Hana pic du
groupe socialiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente mesdames et
messieurs les ministres Mesdames et
Messieurs les rapporteurs chers
collègues
lors de son discours de Toulon en
novembre 2022 Emmanuel Macron énoncé
sans prétention aucune qu'une révolution
copernicienne du mode de conception des
conflits et de notre géopolitique
devaient être adopté néanmoins la
lecture de cette loi de programmation
militaire 2024-2030 et des quelques
pages de revues nationales stratégiques
le texte dont nous allons bientôt
commencer l'examen en séance provoque
moins de bouleversements que le modèle
héliocentrique proposé par l'astronome
polonais en d'autres termes cette loi de
programmation militaire s'inscrit
davantage dans la continuité de la
précédente pour nos armées qu'à la
révolution annoncée par moult superlatif
si nous tenions à saluer l'effort
réalisé afin de garantir la crédibilité
d'une dissuasion nucléaire à sa stricte
suffisance doctrine instaurée par
François Mitterrand à laquelle nous
sommes attachés et qui nous permet de
garder notre autonomie stratégique au
sein de l'Alliance atlantique cette LPM
n'a quoi qu'il en soit monsieur le
ministre rien d'historique comme vous
aimez le répéter
pour la deuxième fois de suite l'examen
de la loi de programmation militaire ni
précédé d'aucun Livre blanc de la
défense et de la sécurité nationale la
revue nationale stratégique qui fixe le
cadre de l'élaboration de la présente
loi navite aucun parlementaire à
participer à son élaboration à sa
réflexion et l'analyse précise et
approfondie nécessaire à notre politique
de défense vous aimeriez sans doute
comme beaucoup être perçu comme un
héritier du général de Gaulle force et
de constater que vous en retenez surtout
la pratique du domaine réservé malgré
vos propos rassurants en commission et
l'adoption d'amendement qui
infléchissent votre premier mouvement
vous participez à conforter la mise à
l'écart du Parlement en matière de
défense pourtant lorsqu'on London à
entendre de tels montants il est
absolument nécessaire de débattre
régulièrement et publiquement des enjeux
qui nous préoccupent en matière de
défense voilà qui renforcerait le lien
armé nation qui vous préoccupe tant
plutôt que la mise en place de
dispositifs coûteux à l'image du ssnu si
nous soutenons évidemment les forts
budgétaires celui-ci ne permettra pas
d'atteindre les 2% du PIB fixé par
l'OTAN comme nous le démontrerons lors
de l'examen à cela se greffe un report
de charge de 100 milliards d'euros de la
précédente LPM un contexte
inflationniste grimpant et
l'intervention des hausses de crédit les
plus importantes après 2027 le pari est
donc un zer2 ajoutons à ce constat nos
difficultés à atteindre les standards au
Tania en matière de préparation
opérationnelle nous aimerions que nos
pilotes volent plus nos marins ne
navigue pas assez nos soldats ne
s'entraînent pas toujours autant qu'ils
le souhaiteraient et trop souvent dans
des conditions dégradées s'il ne fait
aucun doute que les unités dites de
soutien doivent rester une priorité
stratégique notamment en matière de
renseignements et de cybersécurité
admettaient que c'était le PM à ne
vouloir faire aucun choix fait face à
des renoncements notamment concernant
les masses les livraisons de matériel
les unités d'infanterie aussi et sont
réduites si demain la France devait
s'engager dans un conflit de haute
intensité quel serait notre crédibilité
dans celui-ci par extension quel serait
notre poids décisionnelle la France ne
peut plus se rêver en hyperpuissance
militaire comme au siècle dernier et nos
débats doivent aussi nous inviter à
penser le rôle que nous pouvons devons
jouer face aux nouveaux défis
stratégiques comme auprès de nos
partenaires en relation d'alternational
on n'est jamais libre quand on est seul
pendant des mois vous nous avez parlé
d'économie de guerre accélération de la
production massification et augmentation
de la commande publique désormais vous
demander de la souplesse de l'agilité et
n'évoquer l'économie de guerre qu'à
demi-mots mais notre industrie réclame
un engagement ferme sur le long terme
deux conditions sine qua non pour
assurer effectivement l'agilité de mon
dé le logiciel de ce gouvernement est
bloqué sur celui du président en 2019
incapable de prendre en considération
les leçons de la crise covid ou la
guerre actuelle en Ukraine pour
construire des chaînes
d'approvisionnement stable pour recruter
sur le long terme et s'assurer du temps
nécessaire pour former un personnel
qualifié c'est de la confiance de l'État
dont ont besoin nos industriels et non
de vos câbles managériaux en ce sens
c'est vers l'Europe que notre BITD doit
également se tourner dans des projets de
temps long ambitieux et complexes si
vous mentionnez votre attachement au
projet européen de défense tout comme
l'ensemble des socialistes tout reste
pourtant à être démontré
cette loi de programmation est
historique par le contexte géopolitique
dans lequel est s’inscrit et pour rien
d'autre c'est un débat sans faux
semblant sans consensus fallacieux que
le groupe socialiste est apparenté
entend mener nous le devons aux femmes
et hommes qui composent nos armées
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-Charles
Larsonneur du groupe horizon
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la secrétaire d'État
mesdames les ministres monsieur le
rapporteur monsieur le Président mes
chers collègues
l'art de la guerre est en définitive
l'art de garder sa liberté quand on est
né à Brest ville écrasait sous les
bombes à la manière de barkout de Mario
Paul et qu'on a vu se construire le
porte-avions Charles de Gaulle on a le
sens de l'effort du temps long et comme
l'instinct de la programmation militaire
on sait que des équipements à l'étude
aujourd'hui seront encore en service à
la fin de ce siècle on sait ce qu'il en
coûte à un pays de ne pas s'adapter aux
menaces nouvelles de s'abriter derrière
le fantasme d'éternel dividende de la
paix
on s'est enfin qu'un modèle d'armée et
la traduction militaire d'une ambition
géostratégique et diplomatique
c'est-à-dire d'une certaine façon de
concevoir dans le monde de se concevoir
dans le monde pardon et d'être regardé
par lui le choix d'une politique de
défense ambitieuse est nécessairement un
sujet qui s'inscrit dans la durée à cet
égard nous pouvons nous appuyer sur des
politiques de remontées en puissance
crédible depuis 2015 et plus encore
depuis 2017 la LPM 2019-2025 a été tenu
à l'euro près et même dépassé puisque
cette année 2023 aura permis une dépense
supplémentaire de 1,5 milliards d'euros
pour répondre aux besoins liés à la
guerre en Ukraine en munitions notamment
c'est une fondation sérieuse pour
amorcer non seulement la réparation de
nos armées mais aussi leur modernisation
est finalement leur entrée dans un 28e
siècle plus brutal caractérisé par le
durcissement des relations avec nos
principaux compétiteurs stratégiques par
une course aux armements tous azimuts de
l'espace au fond marin en passant par le
cyber
que nous propose cette loi de
programmation pour la période 24 30 de
garantir notre souveraineté et la
préservation de nos intérêts dans
l'Hexagone comme outremer pour un
montant de 413 milliards d'euros
ressources extra budgétaires incluse
c'est un effort strictement nécessaire
taillé au plus juste au regard des
besoins
nous avons déjà eu de nombreux débats
sur la pertinence de cette enveloppe
globale et sur le rythme de la dépense
au cours de la période passée
les marches monsieur le ministre vous
avez souligné qu'il s'agissait d'un
socle d'un plancher à préciser
éventuellement la hausse en fonction des
circonstances en loi de finance annuelle
vous nous avez rassuré à deux égards
d'une part les dépenses exceptionnelles
liées à la guerre en Ukraine ne seront
pas prélevées sur cette enveloppe
d'autre part les recettes extra
budgétaires anticipées à 13 milliards
d'euros feront l'objet si les ressources
prévues n'étaient pas à la hauteur d'une
compensation budgétaire
au sein de cette enveloppe globale
comment apprécier la copie qui nous est
présentée si elle ne permet pas de
regagner significativement en masse ce
qui aurait supposé contenu de
l'inflation du coup unitaire des
équipements et des nouveaux milieux à
protéger au minimum 40 milliards d'euros
supplémentaires c'est une maquette d'une
grande cohérence à mon sens beaucoup
plus innovante qu'on a décrit parfois
qui nous est soumise
ce modèle d'armée soumis à notre
appréciation et non seulement robuste
mais aussi calibré pour gagner en
épaisseur au-delà de les modernisation
absolument indispensables notre
dissuasion nucléaire qui a une
dissuasion de dissuade que c'est
absolument crédible monsieur Roussel
parti
cette LPM opèrent en effet des choix
dont il faudrait pas mésestimer la
profondeur et l'importance
les appuis les soutiens et la logistique
sont renforcés afin que les forces
gagnent en autonomie et en capacité à
durer artillerie feu dans la profondeur
défense solaire durcissement de tout des
plateformes terrestres navales et
aérospatiales ensuite des dépenses ont
été repensées afin de garantir une
activité opérationnelle accrue grâce aux
rehaussement des niveaux d'entraînement
de formation et d'entretien des
matériels
ces deux points sont absolument
essentiels en effet rien ne sert
d’aligner vous la vallée monsieur le
ministre des navires des chats ou des
avions si nous n'avons pas les moyens de
former d'entraîner de soldats de
maintenir un niveau d'entretien et des
soutiens de premier plan pour nous
projeter selon alliance sur tous les
théâtre par exemple en appui à nos
partenaires laissent de l'Europe ou pour
défendre notre souveraineté outre-mer je
note aussi une infection vers plus
d'agilité pour répondre à un statut du
concept du contexte international comme
en témoigne l'attention portée aux
équipements de cohérence l'un des défis
de cette programmation sera de conjuguer
la vie des grands programmes avec la
nécessité de s'adapter en permanence je
veux en outre saluer les investissements
importants consentis dans l'innovation
la préparation de l'avenir et le
renseignement capacités clés pour la
France pour l'obtention d'éléments des
précessions souverains rappelons-nous la
guerre d'Irak en 2003 comme dans
l'échange d'informations avec nos
partenaires j'aurai l'occasion de
revenir en cours d'examens sur les
enjeux de recrutement de fidélisation
sous la tension portée à la vie de nos
militaire et de nocive de la défense par
exemple grâce au plan famille au total
ce projet rempli de 4 objectifs qui
permettent de renforcer notre cœur de
souveraineté conforter la crédibilité de
nos armées d'emploi entretenir et
renforcer l'adaptations permanentes de
nos armées être doté d'une organisation
de commandement réactive afin de
consolider notre autonomie et enfin
répondre à une exigence d'efficacité de
la dépense en se montrant responsable
dans l'emploi de deniers publics c'est
pourquoi c'est avec conviction que le
groupe horizon soutiendra ce projet de
programmation militaire je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Cyrielle
châtelain du groupe écologiste
[Applaudissements]
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues
hier encore nous nous pensions à l'abri
sur un continent en paix le spectre de
la guerre définitivement éloigné
aujourd'hui nous ne pouvons que
constater le retour de la guerre de
haute intensité sur le territoire
européen le nouvel élan dangereux des
États autoritaires et la lente montée
des gouvernements et libéraux en Europe
nous avons longtemps cru que le guerres
étaient derrière nous que nos
démocraties nous interdépendances
économiques nous mettaient à l'abri nous
nous sommes cru protégés et nous avions
tort nous avions tort comme nous avons
tort lorsque nous choisissons de
continuer à vivre comme si notre planète
avait des ressources infinies
aujourd'hui nous n'avons plus le choix
et le réveil est brutal à cause de notre
aveuglement la moitié de l'humanité
connaît au moins une fois par an une
grave pénurie d'eau 3,3 milliards de
personnes vivant des zones déjà
vulnérables au changement climatique et
entre 8 à 30% des terres agricoles
mondiales pourraient devenir un
cultivable nous sommes confrontés aux
limites de notre terre et au risque de
conflits que cela implique alors oui il
est nécessaire de garantir je pense qui
permettra à nos armées de fonctionner
que cela soit par l'amélioration des
conditions de travail et de rémunération
mais également par l'investissement dans
le maintien aux conditions
opérationnelle des équipements ainsi les
efforts réalisés sur ces sujets sont
pertinents car aussi puissantes
soient-elles une armée doit d'abord se
penser à hauteur d'homme et de femmes
garantir le bon fonctionnement de notre
armée comme de tout service public et
nécessaire mais dans un monde
profondément incertain une loi de
programmation militaire ne peut se
contenter d'additionner les euros elle
doit impulser une vision stratégique de
notre défense et anticiper les conflits
de demain malgré les grands mots
d'amplification de transformation cette
LPM s'inscrit dans la continuité et
surtout ne prend pas en compte la
complexité du monde d'aujourd'hui et
encore moins l'imprévisibilité de celui
de demain les crises et des dangers
s'accumulent mais notre stratégie de
défense reste un songé si la nouvelle
revue nationale stratégique a signé la
véritable entrée du climat dans les
questions de défense on peine à
retrouver dans cette LPM une
transposition satisfaisante de cette
tribus de conscience un amendement
écologiste du député Julien Bayou a été
adopté en commission c'est un premier
pas mais dans le cas de nos travaux nous
devons aller plus loin
pour les écologistes trois avancées
majeures sont malheureusement absentes
alors qu'elles auraient pu démontrer une
réelle transformation de notre politique
de défense et notre capacité à faire
face aux nouveaux risques climatiques et
géopolitiques le premier élément qui
fait défaut à cette LPM concerne
l'association plus forte du Parlement
dans les décisions en matière de défense
elle relève aujourd'hui encore
exclusivement du président et de
l'état-major une grande démocratie une
démocratie telle que la nôtre ne doit
pas avoir peur des grands débats
stratégiques en matière de défense dans
un moment où de nombreux pays
affaiblissent leur démocratie sous
couverts de mieux répondre aux enjeux
sécuritaires répondons par un geste de
confiance dans nos institutions et dans
notre Parlement votons le mandat que la
France donna l'OTAN contrôlons davantage
les
exportations d'armes aujourd'hui nous
devons avoir confiance dans le débat
démocratique sur les questions de
défense nous devons aller vers plus de
transparence aujourd'hui que ça soit le
Parlement que ça soit les Français nous
sommes en capacité de comprendre et de
prendre les décisions les plus à même le
second sujet qui nous inquiète c'est
l'absence d'une véritable dynamique
ambitieuse en vue de l'avènement d'une
Europe de la défense le 13 juin dernier
le président Macron avait annoncé
vouloir une défense européenne beaucoup
plus forte il y avait promis que cette
nouvelle VPN permettrait de contribuer à
la construction de l'autonomie
stratégique européenne à la lecture de
ce projet de loi nous en sommes encore
loin le groupe écologiste défend la
nécessité d'affancer résolument vers une
Europe de la défense qui permettra de
mutualiser les moyens en matière de
défense donc de les rendre soutenable
d'asseoir une armée et une diplomatie
qui pèse fortement sur la scène
internationale de construire une base
industrielle et technologique européenne
avoir afin d'avoir des armées plus
résilientes ou choc de haute intensité
et d'amplifier le projet fondateur au
cœur de l'Europe celui de la paix entre
les peuples européens
la recherche et la préservation de la
paix et d'ailleurs le dernier grand
absent de cet LPM dans cette période
d'incertitude tous les états y compris
les États européens augmentent leur
dépense de défense s'il existe des
guerres légitimes contre un état
agresseur comme c'est le cas en Ukraine
il n'exige jamais de guerre juste les
écologistes porteront donc
l'augmentation des moyens de la
diplomatie comment imaginer avoir une
politique de défense efficace si la
diplomatie française est affaiblie dans
un souci de sécurité commune de toute
l'humanité les écologistes défendront
aussi une politique de sortie
multilatérale de la dissuasion nucléaire
nous devons sortir de cette dépendance
et commencer à penser de nouveaux types
de dissuasion la France doit porter une
voie claire une voix ferme une voix
forte sur la non-prolifération et tracer
le chemin d'une interdiction des armes
nucléaires
alors que la guerre faitra sur le
continent européen et que l'incertitude
sur les contours du monde de demain
continuent de grandir nous ignorons
l'héritage que nous laisserons à nos
enfants pour les écologistes nous ne
souhaitons leur léguer ni une planète
détruite ni un monde en guerre je vous
remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
Dupont-Aignan
madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre chers collègues j'ai
suffisamment alerté au cours de mes
mandats précédents sur la baisse de
notre effort de défense pour ne pas
aujourd'hui me réjouir de voir cette loi
de programmation militaire
consolider notre force de dissuasion
vitale et réarmée notre pays
cependant ce n'est pas parce que vous
faites mieux que vos prédécesseurs qui
ont désarmé la France que vous n'avez
pas encore et que nous n'avons pas
encore une marge de progression c'est
pourquoi avec Véronique BESSE député non
inscrit je proposerai des amendements
visant à ajouter 21 milliards d'euros de
crédit pour dépasser en 2030 à l'image
du Royaume-Uni non pas 2% du pipe comme
vous le prévoyez mais 2,5 qui sont pour
nous un strict minimum notre proposition
répond à quatre objectifs compenser
l'effet de l'inflation qui grignotera
votre budget vous le savez bien de 30
milliards d'euros améliorer la condition
de vie des militaires pour éviter la
multiplication des démissions qui
aiblissent nos armées accroître nos
équipements indispensables à notre
présence maritime avec un second
porte-avion et 15 frégats
supplémentaires enfin conserver notre
indépendance technologique en nous
donnant les moyens autour de nos
industriels tricolores de produire de
manière indépendante l'avion du futur
plutôt que de perdre du temps dans les
sables mouvants du fameux SCAF européen
ce débat autour de la loi de
programmation militaire et donc vitale
pour l'avenir de nos pays pour le moral
de nos soldats qui risquent leur vie
pour notre liberté mais il en est un
autre encore plus urgent qui manque
cruellement à notre représentation
nationale et je veux en parler
aujourd'hui le débat sur l'engagement de
notre pays en Ukraine au fil des mois
mes chers collègues l'ampleur des
livraisons d'armes françaises et surtout
la récente annonce de la formation de
pilote ukrainien sur Mirage 2000
préalable obligatoirement à la livraison
d'avions de chasse français nous
conduisent de fait à la cobelligence
dangereuse avec la Russie c'est un choix
crucial qui envertu de l’article 35 de
notre Constitution devrait être soumis à
l'autorisation du Parlement une chose
était de condamner l'entrée des troupes
russes en Ukraine et je l'ai condamné de
sanctionner cette atteinte à la
souveraineté et j'ai approuvé les
sanctions une autre est de participer à
une surenchère guerrière aux côtés de
responsables ukrainien qu'on ne maîtrise
pas
qui ne cache plus leur volonté
d'attaquer et de déstabiliser la Russie
l'histoire de la Première Guerre
mondiale mes chers collègues nous a
appris qu'un conflit territorial mal
géré pouvait conduire à une catastrophe
planétaire en déclarant que la France
s'alignera c'est ces mots sur les
conditions de paix et le moment choisir
par le président Zelinski Emmanuel
Macron se lit les mains par avance et
interdit à notre pays de proposer avant
qu'il ne soit trop tard un plan de paix
bien sûr équilibré au moment où les deux
camps en présence sont épuisés par les
combats et où l'Ukraine devient le champ
de bataille martyr de l'Europe ce n'est
pas faire preuve de faiblesse mes chers
collègues mais tout au contraire de
courage comme le pape François vient de
le dire que de vouloir stopper
l'engrenage militaire en proposant un
chemin vers la paix
la France fidèle à sa tradition
d'indépendance gauliennes sonores
aujourd'hui de proposer l'autonomie
constitutionnelle du Dombasle qui était
d'ailleurs prévu par les accords de mins
et qui n'ont pas été respectées non plus
par l'Ukraine le retrait bien sûr des
troupes russes avec la mise en place de
casque bleu de l'ONU sur la ligne de
front et un accord de sécurité européen
tel qu'en son temps la veille imaginée
Jacques Chirac et Dominique de Villepin
prévoyant notamment la neutralité hors
de l'OTAN et hors de l'Union Européenne
de l'Ukraine Henri Kissinger ce grand
diplomate n'a cessé de mettre en garde
l'Occident contre la tentation de
pousser la Russie dans les bras de la
Chine et de s'isoler du reste du monde
la France en s’alignant unilatéralement
sur Madame vanderleyen qui n'a aucune
légitimité démocratique et sur un
président bydon très contesté en matière
de politique étrangère au Congrès
américain
commet commet une faute géopolitique
historique dans un monde de plus en plus
multipolaire celui qui avait imaginé
anticiper le général de Gaulle en ne le
comprenant plus et en ne l'incarnant
plus notre pays perd son indépendance
perd sa crédibilité perd son influence
on le voit tous les jours en Afrique en
Amérique latine et en Asie plus nous
laissons pourrir ce conflit plus nous
l'alimentons plus nous transformons le
continent européen en champs de bataille
du monde plus nous affaiblissons les
nations européennes nous préparons à 21e
siècle sous la domination complète de la
Chine et des États-Unis voilà pourquoi
une loi de programmation militaire qui
renforce nos armées ses biens mais ce
qu'on fait des armes c'est encore plus
important est-ce vraiment l'intérêt de
la France de continuer ainsi sans
indépendance est-ce vraiment même
l'intérêt de l'Europe que d'alimenter
cette guerre folle merci
je vous remercie la discussion en
général et close suspension de séance de
2 minutes